and welcome everybody to the
i am not a gm tournament it's
grand mastermon hamilton joined by
national master james canty the third
what's up my man
what's up bro i'm excited to commentate
with you man it's
always an honor chilling with the boys
for the boys and we're here today with
i am not a gm i'm excited yeah and then
people should remember
uh yourself uh james because you had a
match in this tournament
and if i may say so myself you put up a
damn good performance and a lot of
people
still remember that performance against
levy so
so people should remember you and
hopefully they do but now
we've got to bring your talents up to
the commentary booth with myself
let's remind people of the format for
the i am not a gm
tournament there's the main bracket it's
single elimination
knockout um important to remember the
time control there's a five plus one
portion
a three plus one portion and then a one
plus one portion with
varying times that you're going to be
playing for for those uh
time controls and of course the winner
advances to
the next round of the bracket um
as for the prizes james i mean these
these guys are
these guys will be playing for some cash
which is nice to see and they split that
cash
you know according to the score of the
match so
even if you lose the match then you
could still be walking away
with a decent payday what do you think
about you know making sure that that
as long as you score some points you can
still secure
uh some cash on the side hey man i think
that's fair i think that's fair of
course chess.com did a great job of of
course doing the event and doing the
prize fun like that it's awesome man
you're playing for something
and it's a lot of nerves there and lots
of uh we don't
know what's going to happen so it's it's
definitely exciting and of course this
payday is
always good right playing chess can
never be bad to get paid right
absolutely with the 10 000 total prize
fund
the the i am not a gm tournament keeps
everybody everybody happy win or lose so
these players are playing for a lot of
money and let's remind people to bracket
because
um a lot of matches have happened so far
and there's still a lot of matches to
come
so we can see the the bracket shaping up
there today
we are um handling the match of carissa
yet
against teddy coleman um so that that
match you're gonna see
today and that's gonna start to shape
the total bracket but
james as you look at that bracket there
do any of the the
uh strike you as uh as maybe some
exciting ones coming up
uh exciting definitely costia costa
actually kosty is really strong one of
my best friends actually i'm really cool
with him eric rosen as well i mean he
got e rose in today's match
like every time this match is on and no
matter what time of the day it's on
i'm actually watching it i may be laying
in the bed sleeping but i am watching it
because this stuff is
it doesn't get better than this today
yeah yeah i know this is uh this is the
prime time entertainment most of the
people or hopefully a lot of people in
chat right now
maybe they're still feeling that buzz
james from the match
the the armageddon match that we just
saw between jordan and annie to conclude
tata steel so
if you guys still feeling that blitz
adrenaline then yeah you guys are on the
perfect channel because we got tons more
blitz for you
two players who are going to be
competing you see them on screen there
teddy coleman and carissa yep and teddy
has actually played in this format
before
james did you catch the last i am not a
gm um i think
who did he play did he play levy last
time or i can't remember
didn't have the match with levy okay i
remember he did play levy
yeah and he won he won that match if oh
i'm not mistaken i don't remember that
oh yeah he did he played twice yeah he
won that
wow he actually did quite well um in the
tournament overall i think he made it to
the semi-finals
um as i recall alina and john
i think made it uh maybe made it all the
way but it was at least those those
three four in the in the semi-finals
finals so
uh we know that he's done super well in
this format i am not a gm despite the
fact that
you know his seating might not be the
highest overall so
i think what people need to remember
about teddy's sort of a
technical solid player really really
principled
doesn't like to go for anything too
extravagant and when things get a bit
tactical
it could get messy um now what do you
know about carissa yep because i
off the bat i would say that that's the
exact opposite style yeah that's the
exact opposite i know and
carissa yep is i'm like a carissa you
know style
all day my favorite players tal she
likes tactics swashbuckling chess i
remember even reading her report
she uh beat her uh youngest youngest
female
master ever actually to beat a
grandmaster
actually i think she beat her first gm
at like maybe 10 i mean
i think it was 10 or 11 right i just did
the stats i was like wow 10 or 11
b to gm and like she's very tactical
even they say about her game her style
is very creative just like how we saw
um you know van forest today or in the
whole
you know tournament for tata steel so
i'm excited to see what happens is this
opposite styles
gary kasparov karkov type thing you know
exactly and uh we're actually off here
as we see uh teddy and karissa
uh teddy with the white pieces to start
things off this is the five plus one
portion
five minutes and then every time these
players make a move they'll gain one
second on the clock so it's actually
not a lot of time and one of the things
that players constantly forget
is one second is barely enough time to
process the move and make one of your
own
so we do see people flag in this format
all the time and straight off the bat we
have a king's indian defense
oh king's indian what do you like
kingzine what about you i'm a ki i'm kid
for life
that's how i feel at this point what
about you bro uh well i play d4 so i
i get a lot of uh king xenian against me
so i'm very used to
these type of positions uh from the
white side but uh it sounds like we got
two different perspectives here which is
which is perfect for
the commentary booth well actually okay
so here in this king's indian i'm not
liking her position already
so she's this is this doesn't feel right
but uh of course we do have f5 coming in
very quickly
how do you feel about white i'm actually
going to say white's white's doing
excellent right now
but what about you yeah definitely the
the h4 g5 like pawn on g5 is generally
very strong so
uh if black goes something like f5 or f6
uh white has to make a choice are you
going to take that guy on on f6 or
you're just going to leave the pawn on
g5
and follow up with something like f3
instead um black is going
full queen side knight c5 maybe this
knight drops into b4
c6 could also open things up but right
now you might be surprised but
teddy i think he's really thinking about
castling along and a lot of people might
be like whoa
like why would i ever castle long into
black's attack but
surprisingly that's one of the main
ideas in the king's indian
it's actually very sharp almost like a
yugoslav from uh the dragon type
positions in the sicilians cats and
queen side sack sag mate like bobby
fischer there it is castle queenside f4
moving to bishop queen h2
and do what we do it's it's definitely
going to be uh
very scary that move was bad though oh
is that the pawn
it's just a central pawn and you can see
the the reaction there it's as that's a
huge blunder to start off this match and
quickly taken by carissa that is not a
move that is very scary
uh now i mean especially now f5 my
bishop can swing into f5
the c file is open this is uh man
immediately change you cannot drop that
pawn any other pawn you might be able to
give up but that one
that's going to be a big swing as you
see the engine already or the evaluation
bar already
flipping into black's favor so what do
you do here now mod queenie one that
feels garbage it feels i might have to
yeah it's tough because you know queen
queen c2 always seems to walk
into an eventual night before in the
future
and you know bishop f5 sort of on that
on that diagonal to the queen so
queen c2 doesn't feel great queenie one
might be necessary
but it's a hard move to play because
yeah i mean you're not used to being in
this but she's just gonna bring her
knight back bishop at five
five oh my goodness bishop f5 and we
live this is over
this feels like this is already over now
of course there's a lot of counter play
left these games can go
you know either way sometimes i know
from personal experience i mean um you
know
that's that stalemate i still have
dreams about that still made against
levy
so still have nightmares about it but at
the same time it does happen guys you
will see this kind of stuff
you know bishop f5 it can happen maybe i
don't know what do you even play here
right now
a3 the thing the thing about carissa is
you know i was actually told that she
was warming up for this match like
waiting for it to start by doing puzzle
rush
puzzles so i feel like she's in the zone
like
that she wasn't going to miss that pawn
any day of the week she's warmed up and
i feel like maybe teddy's a little bit
rusty coming in
maybe hasn't got any warm-up games in
because i i can say firsthand
my first games of the day always super
rusty so yeah that could be what we're
seeing here
that's that's correct first games of the
day are kind of rusty especially if
you're just starting you haven't played
any that's why it is good to practice i
always tell you know students about like
sports wise
in every other sport even chess outside
of chess what do they do before they do
before they play they warm up doing
layups shooting you know basketball
stretching whatever sport that is
chess is the same way you definitely
need to be warming up before you come in
here especially as a big boy match like
today
yeah and uh we could see already a big
result for carissa game one coming away
with a win but she's got to prosecute
this advantage i
don't mind the move e4 opening up that
dark square bishop
maybe like queen e7 to e5 yeah
a4 a3 always get some some ideas there
open up the diagonal but
we just saw a very committal decision by
teddy he just gave up his dark square
bishop and that's
like that's pretty much a no-no in the
king's indian yeah
actually that's correct now my dark
score bishop just like you said e4
very tempting here e4 looks good
sometimes and maybe even like bishop e6
and b5
yeah definitely creative type chess here
i even see knight b3 being a potential
sacrifice at the right moment so this is
very fun
and carissa is in her element right now
i think she should take this game here
with precision but of course she does
have to stay precise here and not allow
counter play for teddy yeah completely
really like bishop e6
b5 i think black can afford to be pretty
reckless with the position right now
you can see that evaluation bar is
nearly
nearly right at the end there so that's
a big big advantage for carissa
and keep in mind she's only up one pawn
so if you have such a big advantage like
minus four
that's almost as if you're up a pawn and
a piece right so if she's only up a pawn
that means her position is so good it's
almost like being up a piece
e4 played she says look i don't care if
that can be taken
uh the exactly what i was talking about
a3 and that bishop opening up
this is looking real dangerous for teddy
here
very very scary here so of course the
eval bar switched a little bit there i
think because of the trailers going back
but uh the trade a3 happens now after b3
right it's kind of uh it doesn't feel
like i'm i'm that bad anymore actually
as white i feel like there's definitely
some misplay there something a little a
little bit sharper and this is five one
she had she has more time i think she
should have spent a little bit more time
there
to figure this one out because white is
starting to consolidate slightly
not enough basically i mean 95 and even
sacrificing on f6 can be good eventually
but
he's defending he's defending right now
and it's not clear actually how she's
going to crush this and d6 is weak and
a3
will be weak as well in an in game but
those bishops are monsters
yeah one thing to keep an eye on is if
the queens trade off the board
really benefits teddy so if these queens
just disappeared right now
there's a case for uh for white even
being potentially better
but with those queens on the board i i
have a hard time believing
in the position following your plan
bishop e6
b5 i would just toss in there at some
point
um b5 bishop c7 throw the whole sink at
him and then 1983 he played king d2 he's
like yeah we're running for the hills
to the other side of civilization so he
is trying to get away here
king the d2 rookie a is we see a slight
head shake from teddy
shake it out danny like yo i what did i
do here but it happens there's a lot of
chests left here
lots of tesla so you know kind of
getting the kinks out warming up and
maybe he'll play a better game
of course uh in the next games with
white yeah
you said he's getting the kinks out but
i thought you said he's getting the king
out warming up
his king is getting warmed up that's for
sure it's getting some uh
getting some stretches and we didn't
think he would be going for a jog but
here it is it might even end up all the
way on the king's side at g2
so we'll see where he goes with this
knight i think he's got to at least
finish development
knight f3 or knight e2 i'm waiting for
these moves to happen but he does not
want to see queen b2
jeez i mean look at the evaluation bars
losing his mind
like what is like going crazy i mean
there's not even a like obvious move to
make his black right now
because it's not too obvious bishop f5
is not good bishop g4 of course not
bishop b6 is like you really really
don't want to go there
so like what is it maybe it's b5 yeah
i'm
really on the b5 train take that uh
bishop b7 to follow
get your rook to the c file everything
with tempo
really big fan of that also d5 can
happen after you go b5 to get that pawn
out of the way
yeah that's correct b5 uh knight f3 here
she's getting low on time they both
already got one second increment there
so uh she's trying to figure this out i
do
understand yeah bishop d7 i understand i
understand i have to develop in a knight
definitely a more modest approach bishop
d7 yeah bishop d7
okay back on carissa now yeah you have
to just play this b5 just don't even
think about it just play the move
here it saves time also teddy's almost
under a minute here and one second
increment it seems like enough time but
especially in the time scrambles
it's definitely tough when you're when
you're in a tough position like this as
well
bishop c6 is on the board now well
bishop e4 is a threat
and oh my goodness it's unsurprising
that teddy is going to lose material at
some point in this game i mean
i've actually been surprised he hasn't
lost material yet
and another really annoying move to keep
in mind is if this rook moves like g1 or
e1
sometimes even just queen h2 and taking
on f2 taking on h4
like all the pawns just fall in this
position it's really tough to hold
yeah and actually bishop e4 is queen
trap or it's close no it's just material
you can play queen c3 but i mean it's
close to being trout even moving the
queen hits it again
so yeah like you said queen h2 yeah
combining that whole plan is just nasty
it's just over from there f4 yikes king
in the center of the board
chilling around like a little box there
queen and knights and the king and that
little square
and uh check is yikes
playable followed by b4 though
teddy has a move there but yeah you make
a good point look at this this box here
and no pawns are left on the second rank
to defend
interesting and he's holding like this
is miraculous this is a miraculous
defense right here
i mean it's over but it's not over yet i
mean b4 look at this this man's holding
over but it's not over
it's over but it's not africa
this is amazing here rook's hanging
queens hanging king's in the center
this is the type of king's indian
defenses that we like to see i'm a big
fan of this kind of stuff now i know
you're not of course with the white
pieces here
oh i'm not a fan of this is white nope
don't sign me up far away from this one
right
oh my goodness this king by the way
after something like rook c8
we see this crazy theme of the king just
being
sandwiched between these two open files
yikes
yikes wrong end of the sandwich here
rookie seven and rook a to ea doubling
oh
yeah rick b man what a defense like he's
defending
well he was defending this doesn't look
oh he has a move queen b5
what in the world no checks yeah i mean
what a defense and he's getting closer
on time it's a time scramble now
wow this is amazing to even make this a
game
um
that is not a move i can't believe this
i mean well actually i can i mean i i
had a draw with levy that same draw yeah
i remember that
yeah wow it can't happen check check and
we look like we might be taking a
perpetual here
take she says no perpetual but now the
advantage is gone he's out of this
and she has two seconds on the clock
queen takes f4 king c2
queen e3 oh yeah i guess that does work
i think bishop e5 is nice yeah you get
the king of g7 and now white has no
checks i think white should lose this
game
yeah is hanging and there's no way to
checkmate that king
bam there it is uh-oh lev oh he did so
now you just trade
snap snap wow he was doing great and
then he's like i can't believe this
oh my goodness right man that's game one
over to carissa there wow and that's
that's a good one for the old heart rate
to start off and wow
just as i was reeling from the last game
we get e4
to start off this one she disrespecting
him right now
i mean she's definitely disrespecting
him and if she win this game too like
i'm about to check her repertoire
that's uh that's crazy she's just like
b4
and then don't and don't even think
about it wow yep
some people might chalk that up to a
mouse slip but that's a that's a very
real opening for those wondering
that is correct there are a couple names
but you know the orangutang is one of my
favorites my preferred uh names for this
opening b4 there
yes and the polish as well
and i'm just looking at the the webcams
as well and i'm just looking at carissa
she got she got the hand on the cheek
just
around yeah she's bored it's a great way
to put it
hans was like this a lot uh shout out to
hans neiman a newly minted gm too hans
was like that i remember
he was always just bored at the board
and it would be like a disrespectful
board in a way
you're like man how are you bored but
he's so strong he's like i already know
what i'm doing like
make a move bro hurry up right that's
how it is but it's at the same time like
many
just players are like that but she's in
the zone it looks like she's almost
sleeping right now
you know like how much talent is packed
in that brain that
that it's uh she's just not worried
about the position she has under control
and in that last game
um i think a lot of us might have taken
that draw but
she she wanted more the whole time she
was looking for a way to not take that
draw because she was winning that whole
game
yeah correct they're winning a whole
game and of course they're they're going
to go back i'm sure down in line but
a different way because said he had a
terrible position there so he's going to
he's going to have to come up with
something
completely different for the next one
here now in this polis position here
these orangutans here aman i know you're
known for playing
um many weird openings and things like
that jerome gambits and stuff like that
and uh what's my favorite the uh the
england gambit the england gambit that
you play
and the queen sack and you miraculously
beat a lot of players with it guys don't
try this at home
chat but please don't you can but you
got to watch him on
videos first to see how you actually
play it it was actually
miraculous i've seen him be gm's with it
and i'm like he's sacked the queen
on like move four and he wins the game
still
it's it's all about you know sometimes
you get the job done but would i
would i bring it out in a tournament for
cash you know that i'd have to
i'd have to question myself there i
don't know if i would but we see carissa
bringing out b4
when everything's on the line so that's
it that's a different type of confidence
that's true that's a different type of
confidence right there
yeah you absolutely are right there he's
like she's like b4
you don't see any sweat on her at all
she's not like shaking
at all i mean just stone cold killer
here today she
with b4 as well i'm curious to see the
other openings that may happen
um as well she's a big favorite of cena
was she played i think greg
the last time i think she played last
time as well but
she played greg and she played they went
through a lot through the vienna
vienna gambits back and forth or
something it's actually
kind of a solid position for teddy which
is really much really in his style i
would say
um h5 he's looking to just tickle the
idea of maybe playing h4 and if white
plays g4 the dark squares are a little
bit weaker in that position
this bishop on v2 isn't the best just
because you got that
pawn on c3 in front of it which is why
teddy is probably not
too interested in necessarily taking on
b4 um because maybe white just opens up
the bishop
yes that's correct here actually and i
am i'm a fan of
white's position but also black is
pretty stable solid as well
figuring out where we're actually going
to put our king is a dilemma actually
i'm actually not sure where to castle to
as white hasn't castled either
so plants for both sides what do you
think in here i'm on
well i'm thinking that white might be a
little scared of king side castle
because of the potential bishop takes g3
and you just never know what the the
repercussions of you know f takes queen
takes followed by some wacky
knight g4 move at the end could get wild
so
um that that looks scary to me so i
think carissa is thinking twice
about putting her king on the king's
side but on the queen side that looks
even scarier because black is a single
move away
just piece play here but of course what
do you expect in a way
as well starting with b4 you will have a
wild position
anyway especially not doing a main line
stuff against b4 usually i think the
mainline theory is e5
and letting them capture on on e5 as you
take the b4 pawn giving up a center pawn
for the wing pond just for rapid
development is the key
in the polish orangutan ideas and plans
but here this is completely different
it's like some
hybrid modified version i have never
seen before
so they are definitely playing some
chess here today just
regular chess and this is exciting this
is the type of chess that i think
carissa excels in and teddy is
he's got his work cut out for him
because he might get the advantage in
some of these games but
he's going to have to work to protect it
knight g6 he sort of wants to play h4
g4 knight f4 again utilizing those dark
squares
i think bishop e5 is probably not
the craziest move sometimes they play
that even though d4 is possible
just to go back and say okay you know
you blocked your bishop now what
yeah yeah c4 is open
that's nice e5 e5 is probably too much
right now right
it's probably too much because the d5 is
hanging actually in that and that's
this um or yeah it's just getting the
rook over it looks looks a little risky
i agree
um there's also like bishop takes g3
you know queen takes g3 f1 f4
that's some real you might be
calculating that and then rook g1 and
then
knight g4 no that can't be right that
would be wild
but you have to calculate it and that's
the thing that's what they go hey there
it is he goes forward
he's in on it he's like let's go we are
here guys we have been
we've been praising the attacking chest
the aggressive chest from carissa the
tactics that she's been doing but
but what about teddy over there he's got
a one-two punch of his own bishop takes
g3
the queen's coming down and it almost
feels like white's pieces are sidelined
they're all on the queen side and the
action is now all on the king side
teddy is swinging right now he is like i
don't care about anything i'm going to
throw everything i have at you pawn
takes g3 queen takes
it's on the board king f1 force and then
we have knight f4 or knight
h4 um you're probably f4
yeah f4 feels like it just hits more
things um
so i would go a knight f4 yeah
so now here's the critical moment is
after rook to g1 does knight g4 work
or like do you play h4 but then you do
allow bishop takes f6 removing one of
the pieces
and uh maybe even moving well you can't
move the bishop h3 is going to be
hanging in many cases so you might even
have d4
as from white d4 swinging the queen back
over for defense yeah
that's important that's important i
think there's there's a lot of potential
ideas
for black like rook h6 h4 knight takes
h3
um knight g4 was mentioned queen e3
also hits this pawn on e2 for well
checkmated
yeah not a bad start hitting the knight
so queen d1 might be forced to hold
everything but that's a very passive
move extremely passive here yeah there
it is queen d1 and black's winning
like wow nice exactly your idea
of d4 to bring the queen over to defend
is no longer possible so now if i'm
looking at
hey how does white you know unravel here
i'm not seeing a clear path i'm not even
seeing it yeah and even sometimes in
some cases shutting the bishop out
completely like d4
just so you can play d4 just to be able
to shut the bishop out to be able to use
the knight on f6
because you really would like to use a
second you need another piece we know
this for a fact you can't do this with
just a queen and a knight
and we would love to keep pieces on but
there is a elimination factor so bishop
takes off six so
here's a criticism about getting ahead
of it not knight g4
uh ahead time right now it works they
they like it
they like it actually and then g3 rook
h2 i mean this is
wow tau would be proud here this is oh
and it's played
night james this is gonna this is gonna
be a fun one it's on the board big fella
queenie one knight it's two mate and we
great so you can't do queen e1
um you have to take this knight you
literally have to take this night
there's no other move to play
you're already getting made it or you
take tonight after taking the night pawn
takes he sacked two pieces here
teddy is hey look at him in the camera
see how close he is to the screen
yeah yeah because he knows he needs to
calculate a checkmate here because he's
now down two pieces
yeah he's down two pieces here correct
and he's winning like that's crazy so if
g3 queen e1
so we have g3 and rook h2 that's like
the only moves right
yep those look like the main ones here
um rook h2 g3
trying to think of knight h3 is also um
an idea but it's looking a little slow
that's correct takes then we have to
take and then push h2 and then do all
the extra work
don't have any checks yet this is a
complicated one this
is very complicated look on g2 oh yeah
you can do that you can't even take that
oh my goodness that's an important thing
you can't even take it maybe wait maybe
you can king takes queen check
king f2 and then what well no king takes
rook h2
oh my gosh stop don't do this to them
this is the puzzle rush victory
this is a family channel oman king takes
rook h2 guys if we see that
oh my god but the thing is karissa's so
good at tactics i think she's probably
seeing that yeah and she moves the night
makes her own threat against the queen
what's it gonna be now if you leave the
queen there funny enough you actually
can take back
and win the queen yourself but remember
you started this down two pieces you
gotta be careful yeah correct queen h3
and queen h3 at least keeps you know
discoveries alive with knight e3 being
the intention he plays queen g3 instead
queen h3 would be a little bit more
direct but he did have that uh where it
takes g2 so probably not yeah queen g3
yeah yeah afterwards
oh man look at the evaluation bar it's
saying you have two rooks and a piece
you have two rooks and a knight right
now wow
two roxanna knight this is uh over but
what's the move
it was not that one apparently the thing
is knight e3 bishop takes e3 covers
f2 and your queen is being hit so it's
not the simplest
um dang it's equal now yikes that was
really not the move rick h2
because you have to throw in a queen h3
basically you have to like go
knight takes e3 throw queen h3 in um
rook g2 take it and then take back on e3
so you have to stay down a piece i think
at this point yeah that's correct
teddy's mad too you see him shake his
head like oh bro what did i do
queen f3 stop it no no not queen f3
oh man this hurts this hurts big blunder
whoa wow 93 ouch
okay wonders left and right yeah queen
side castle maybe
queen shy castle that's correct that
would be fun
to see there how do we get the
perspective i guess king g7 e5
yeah e5 is good uh man this is wild this
is what's the time scramble you're going
to see everything this is not going to
be accurate chess here
because there is a time scramble oh my
goodness oh my goodness get him off the
board
whoa oh my gosh no oh my goodness
what oh what is this nonsense look at
her smiling like oh my goodness
let me give it right back to him i'm
sorry i'm sorry teddy
let me give that right back to you check
what are we looking there's so many
pieces that just changed hands there i
can't even keep track of
that yeah king f3
and oh well that pawn is gone that pawn
is gone yeah
what all of a sudden oh my eddie is the
favorite to win now stop this
you guys come on wait what's going on
i think that oh my goodness yes the time
scrambles the time scrambles you see
this kind of chess guys you see this guy
all the time i don't know who's going to
win i have no idea we we think that you
think black's going to win anything
black wins by by time but that is a
completely winning position for black
type that you don't expect someone to
mess up and it's tied one to one
in in this in this match right now james
i think we're just being treated
to some super fun attacking chess and we
might see king's indian again
you know if the players were were you
know high adrenaline after that i mean
there's no breaks for them there's no
breaks for us
that's right i'm excited man this is the
type of chess i wanted to see today i
did not want to be sitting here going to
sleep on stream
watching the positional and uh the
berlin wall
and just like uh very very uh slow chess
i'm excited so we're going to see some
more back to the kid now
yep you know there's best sacrifices on
e4
so not now maybe it's not correct here
but there's a lot of peace sacrifices
that i've seen on e4
especially from some of the greats you
know analyzing and then playing f5
afterwards but
um we'll see what happens here maybe a5
maybe a5 yeah a5 is uh was actually seen
in the last game that they played in
this line it's a very typical idea to
stop b4
basically saying look my knight is going
to stay there the whole game and
generally speaking
although it happened last game white
does not want to play bishop take c5
that's something you generally want to
avoid that's such a valuable piece you
look at all the pawns that teddy's
putting on light squares
it's really important to maintain your
dark square bishop so you don't lose
control
of all these dark squares that you're
weakening with these pawn moves one
hundred percent actually here and this
b4 is
expanding here we see white uh just
having more space this is the advantage
that he goes with here
as black has much or has to play in
swashbuckling style
to actually get some very sharp play on
both sides of the board here
so white's going to try to crush on the
queen side
i don't like his pawn structure though i
think something's like wrong it feels
like
for white it feels like it's off or
loose yeah one of the things that
teddy's actually done in both games
which uh i consider a mistake
is he continuously plays knight takes d5
and black sort of has less space and the
move knight takes d5 always allows black
to play knight takes d5
in the last game there was knight takes
e4 so it was even worse he lost a pawn
but even knight takes d5 is nice for
black you just trade that piece f5 is
quicker to the punch than it was before
if imagine white has a knight on c3 and
black has an eight on f6 in this
position
i think i'd prefer that as white the
extraordinary the space that's 100
correct great uh great job the great
observation
absolutely because here it not even
thinks about where does your king
you know i guess you're going to castle
king side but safety for the king
is for white here is very very shaky
actually even though black's castle
and the space that we did have is not we
used to have space especially central
space but
we have activity for black b4 is a weak
pawn still as well the c
file is open and we have a open king
open king here queen h4 in many cases
actually which is usually not even
an option in many kings indians but here
it's very tempting to even play queen h4
f5 and just go yeah yeah i
i like it and i think that teddy is it
might have to revisit
his the white pieces here against the
king's indian because
i have not liked a single position that
he's had
so far in this match you might need to
change this opening up yeah
you might need to chase open it up
that's correct i understand that too
if you're not having great success with
it it's not you're not getting the
positions you usually are looking for
you do have to have a secondary uh
opening or something like that you know
that's one
thing correct here rook c8 is on the
board i'm loving black's position
yeah oh bishop b5 at least is a
consideration but
yeah just to stop the castling but you
know there are other ideas knight g3 he
wants to say look
uh that f5 idea that you had that's not
happening anymore uh you're going to
lose all the light squares if you try
that
that is correct actually many people
would actually still try to force it
there i'm one of them so i would like
to calculate it okay maybe it doesn't
work all right because you really want
to get f5
in and then when that happens you
everything's alive the center starts
rolling the bishop gets open because the
g7 bishop is gross now
because we have played e5 and we need to
get this bishop active at some point in
the game
and f5 is a great way to do it but queen
e8 here so she might be actually
preparing f5 usually that happens and
yeah bishop a4 and bishop
b5 as well are pretty uh nice moves
yeah but and the bishop b5 move although
it was possible before
white always had maybe an a4 at their
disposal so now bishop b5
bishop a4 there's ideas like bishop a4
rook c2
and just just everything gets developed
a lot nicer now that you control both of
these squares the knight on a6
eventually that needs to reroute i mean
that piece is not acceptable there if
white plays a3
just locks that piece down for the whole
game we're gonna have to see like knight
c7 knight b5
maybe knight to c3 or knight d4 i think
that's how black needs to activate
correct also king h8 in many lines here
um just going for a decisive king side
attack king h8 with the intention of
f5 and moving and maneuvering every
single piece
to the king side so rook g8 at some
point queen h5 if you're allowed to
queen e7 doubling on the g
file and using every single piece that
you have so he's going pawn hunting
james what do you think of a move like
bishop a7 is that is that is that legal
is that a move
uh well my hat says that's not a move so
we're going to go with that
we're going to go with that answer there
every every fiber of my being says that
bishop a7
is too much it's just too much he's
asking for trouble
that you know that the last game his
king was on d2 the whole game
and i feel like he's asking for trouble
right now because he's just not getting
castle
yeah i mean come on you can't do this
this is elementary stuff guys now of
course the the big boys and
when you get titles and things like that
you know when to break the rules so you
can break rules here but you shouldn't
bend them to the point where you know
this is getting out of hand we took a
bishop
upon on a7 it's completely out of the
game now hitting air basically it's
nothing to do with his bishop anymore
and the king is still in the center we
have a rook on the seventh rank my
system aaron nimsu was like
never give up the seventh and now the
seventh rank or the second rank here for
white
is gone like that's ours and we're just
gonna reroute our pieces and have a
great day here
actually even up on time as well it
looks like knight b5 knight d4
if that bishop takes on d4 uh we've
actually talked about already
you don't want to give up that dark
square bishop in this opening it's so
important
and you know is that the way you treat
your most important piece put it on a7
i have my doubts knight b5 i like
carissa's activity here
but i will say that teddy's position you
know is miles better than last time yeah
definitely f5 is stopped he definitely
has improved and now the bishop on a4
kind of looks
i mean it does look silly it doesn't
kind it is a very silly piece
but we do have many pieces crossing the
the half point here over into black
white's territory which is really good
nice d4 also knight to c3 is tempting
you may have rook c1 in many cases there
but it's a very tempting move
a2 is still hanging as well grabbing a
pawn back and yeah teddy's definitely
consolidating here
playing on a side that he's strongest on
his pawn structure points to the queen
side
so he's actually having some pretty good
play now actually afterwards c1 yeah you
might have to take on a2 and she does
there it is i think this is great if
white goes rook a1 to try to almost trap
that bishop
the problem is black can always slide
the knight into d4 and the queen from e8
let's not forget
is watching over that bishop on a4 um
yes correct and rook a3 britney knight
really nice hitting
that's a super strong move knight c3
just wins here oh yikes gg
well maybe not gg well if we've
learned anything so far james it's never
gg
right next to these guys yeah but it's
definitely a
uh they type this in here i'm up in
exchange so yeah it's material right
it's material no more king side attack
so yeah what do we do now like what do
you even do bishop e3
yeah bishop v3 bring it back remember
guys after the rook played to a3
there was actually nothing that teddy
could do he had to play queen e2 to
guard his bishop
so that was just a good a good tactic by
carissa that she
saw a couple moves ahead and g5 is
played because
uh teddy doesn't want to see that bishop
go to h6
and suddenly get involved on the dark
squares uh he's trying to say look that
bishop's not playing in this game
ah yeah that bishop is not playing in
this game f5 f6 is a move
queen b5 is on the board we trade them
and yeah trades help definitely chariots
help us having that exchange the heavy
pieces are just going to do what they do
here
even game so nothing uh uh or even score
so
we still have more chess here if he does
go down in this game here but he needs
his definite like you said before he is
you got to think of this like the king's
indian has not worked twice
here for you so we have to figure out
what to do before this becomes a big
problem
later on in the in the match yeah
because these are these are
big advantages for carissa at the 25
move mark
you know that's that's barely the the
middle game in some positions so
uh h5 played and i think at some point
uh the move f6
might work out really nicely for carissa
to just break that structure hit the h4
pawn there's no way to defend it
um on top of that you could go the slow
way bishop f8 bishop v7 bishop d8
yeah and actually time is uh not not
existing for teddy here's 20 seconds on
the clock here
even though one second increment it's
still very hard to calculate this
position down in exchange here
not the position we wanted nerves are
there and we're down
so we might as well just uh kind of he's
going to play on
you should you have to play on here but
he's down a lot of time a lot of years
yeah a minute and a half more plus the
advantage and carissa's got
this nice like the rooks aren't doubled
but what they're doing is each rook is
controlling
the only open file in the position so
she's got full control
right now there's no counter play for
teddy i mean he's trying to use his
bishops to get in there but it's just
not working
it's just not working and the evaluation
bar goes crazy here
bishop a4 we probably check is probably
the right move
follow-up is where though uh that bishop
yeah bishop e7 f6 yeah i'm liking that
bishop b7 f6 looks fantastic just put
the king up on g7 or h7 and
that the pressure on the g5 pawn and h4
pawn i think that's the breakthrough
that you need
correct yep f6 is it if f6 is the move
here there it is finally she got it off
bishop takes and that's everything
g5 is coming bishop takes h4 everything
we need kg7 and we're good
gg i think this is nearing the end of
the game
nice technique by carissa um teddy's
still going and we've seen how tricky he
can be as the time gets lower and lower
it seems to almost get trickier
yeah she went rick c7 that rook c2 was
just
over yeah rixie two i agree it just
forces the trade
um now there's there's brooks that can
move around i think bishop takes g3 rook
uh bishop t takes c4 yeah that looks
like a nice conclusion
there's almost mate especially because
it works on g1 but he has king h2
there's almost mate it's like almost
it's gotta be a rick jackson
yeah king h where is it wait where's the
mate
oh he just resigned yeah of course two
seconds on the clock here too as well so
tough game
yep yep all right and um
i think there's actually yeah i was
gonna say i i think we are going to a
break after this game so players are
going to pause
after that one and the adrenaline must
be high right now i mean what's your
take on this match so far
uh james uh carissa teddy it's two to
one
for carissa going into the break what
should they be doing in their in their
break right now checking the lines uh
teddy needs to go back and and check
everything that he did
in the in revamp and and talk to himself
in the mirror
like hey you can do this you can do this
and switch out what he's doing with d4
definitely there you go the motivational
speech necessary
might have to look those kings indian
lines but we love the action so far very
tactical
hope you guys are enjoying we'll be back
with the rest of the five
plus one games right after this
and i hope you guys haven't uh gone
anywhere still here ready for the
rest of the action in the five plus one
portion here
uh the players also got a break we got a
deserved rest
and these have been some very very
exciting and tactical games so far
james and i mean what more could you ask
for as a spectator
right what more could you ask for of
course it's always fun to see uh strong
players play each other and battle it
out and especially when it's
you know something like your style i
love exciting chess like tactics
and just wash buckling styles of chess
and and like noob
kind of things right and especially in
this day and age so it's great to see
this kind of stuff it's great
entertainment not only for us but for
the fans watching today
yeah this is going to be good i like to
see that um so far we've got a lot of
games in the king's indian and that
always speaks to a tactical game no
matter what
um carissa is totally in her style and
usually what happens when a positional
player and a tactical player
meet up is that not many of the games
end up being very positional
it's usually the tactical player that
brings them into their world that is
correct
i know that very very well absolutely
yes it's very fun uh to see this kind of
thing oh and they have moves on the
board e4 c5
so it is a society i think i think this
is from last time i'm not sure if they
can go
underway i think this was the game they
started from last time i wonder actually
are they going to play the same moves
now that's part of the mind games you
know like you play e4 c5 you both go to
a break
and chris is thinking oh maybe i have to
check that sicilian
you know and and teddy is thinking oh
he's playing e4 now okay so
this is something to think about for
both players we're both players yeah i'm
sure they definitely went and hit the
the engine or real quick just to make
sure the lines are correct and checking
things
and then get right back to the action
here so let's see what we have hopefully
they did check some lines though
it's always good to be able to do that
yeah it's nice to have the brake that's
what the brake is for you obviously
can't check lines all the matches going
but you certainly can and you're
encouraged to
during these breaks teddy just make sure
to give full credit to him
tactically speaking because he had that
absolutely
wild game where he launched every piece
forward for the attack
uh it might have been the craziest game
of the match so far actually yeah that
was his and it was a decisive attack of
course it's harder and intense than time
scrambles but man it was nasty
bishop takes g3 double p sacrifice and
almost delivering mate was great here
so sicilian defense here it looks like
we have a special
fesnickoff here or the pelican oscar
something like that
they did go for the sicilian so no no
funny business no tricks and uh this
knight d5
move is is something we've seen quite a
bit at the
top level of chess the i think magnus
has been uh
employing this a lot world championship
fabi this was uh definitely something he
was using here i even seen faruja use
this
as well quite with the black beast is
doing quite well so are you familiar
with this theory with why you're d4
though right you're a d4 player yeah
yeah um but if i if there's a tournament
that you know i'll tune into it's
always the world championship so yeah um
watching watching that broadcast and
hearing the top level commentary on
stuff like this
you know you pick up a thing or two um
black does f5 move very typical
um f3 is because you know black often
wants to just play e4
and stick the knight on e5 bishop f6
white on the other hand
uh really going for like bishop e3 b4
and c5 just expanding on the queen side
because both
both guys are both players rather are
playing on their respective sides of the
board
it's going to be b4 c5 for white and
over here it's going to be black
launching sort of a pseudo
kingside attack that's correct a6 is
actually a move this
and there it is a6 is usually played a
little earlier here in these
fashion cough lines i've played
especially from night dwarfs and uh all
these other societies just getting uh of
course
your your repertoire and your theory um
so you can get better at chess period
from just
studying other openings here a6 though
is nice after knight c3
you do want to press forward a lot of
times with f4 in many cases moving the
knight into h4 and playing almost in the
king's indian attack style
with g5 and g4 and king hey rook g8
especially if you're a tactical player
this is definitely very appealing
um for this it's because if white gets
this attack on the queen side it's it's
almost over
it's almost over d6 is very weak and
then that's going to follow with c5
or c5 d6 thing it's not fun not fun if
you're not attacking
it's not fun if you're getting swung on
right you're getting hit back
that's not exactly and one move we're
going to have to see here is bishop f2
because there's just
no way black can get away with trading
those dark square bishops like that
after queen takes g5 knight f4 there'd
be way too many threats
um keep in mind after knight f4 knight
takes e2
uh that c4 pawn suddenly lacks a lot of
defenders right they take d2 there might
be b5 to follow there might be just
queen c7
yeah be very careful you're not dropping
that yes rick c1 is actually a blunder
it looks like that would be a move but
rick c1 immediately loses tonight takes
e2
and why would you want to play rook c1
well you want to defend upon as a
monster here
queen b3 yikes that seems like that
should be off but maybe it works
they do prefer black a little bit here i
mean who wouldn't pieces look great
weak c pawn but what do you do how about
queen e8
it's like the same idea as last game
he's covering the a4 square and you
might also go queen
g6 and set up some funny business on g2
oh yes i love this idea queenie a queen
g6
and uh delivering mate why not queen h3
is always like this is fun
this is the fun type of chess here and
teddy is definitely showing
a different style of course with the
black pieces but with
white he definitely is uh he needs to
get better with that d4
we have to see some better d4 from teddy
today if he's going to keep playing that
e4 interesting before so like that too
much
pawn takes e4 trying to see what the
idea is is
um yeah what are you trying to do
because we always have bishop d4
right yeah bishop d4 is always following
so sometimes the idea when the knight is
on g6 is you play e4 and after they take
you play f4
and then you put your knight on e5 and
go for a quick f3
but now that the knight is already on f4
i don't think that's the the plan at all
i think it's more like look
pawn takes just pawn takes back and
the bishop is getting opened up i can
just take that pawn on e4
i'm always into like i'm gonna take your
material if it's that you took bishops
right of course knight let's not drop a
piece please okay let's say you said
you're into that yeah just yeah
you know hey i'm gonna take it anyway
okay exactly you got to show me put the
piece hanging there so
pawn takes takes so then what do we do
bishop d4 yeah it has to be probably
just bishop d4 afterwards
rookie one is definitely a an
alternative bishop d4 yep there it is
pawn takes
and then rook e1 or bishop d yeah ricky
one looks
uh reasonable there there's always like
knight d3 in the position honestly
um just to get rid of that dark square
bishop i don't know if it's worth it
though
um you know potentially at the the cost
but with rookie one knight d3 looks
looks pretty reasonable
weak pawn on e4 yeah it's very in 93
yeah but of course as uh
as the pawn advances the more it
advances the more it becomes
weaker it becomes very weak as it
advances by itself and there is rookie
one now
rookie one is on the board e4 is coming
yeah there's a few ways to play i mean
you can just obviously take that bishop
is completely reasonable
um knight d3 uh as well i i really want
to get the queen out to like
g i was just about to say that like can
we do queen e8 anyway
anyway but bishop d well bishop d3 takes
with the knight so
you have to be careful because we are
just immediately hopping into an x-ray
after rookie one so
rookie one i mean maybe something bishop
f3 like that might work well that's kind
of annoying
queen e8 bishop three so um yeah
i want to play that so bad though
sometimes you just do it and hope for
the best
but in this situation though you know
it's a lot on the line here sometimes
she's also up a game
you know or he's he's down the game yeah
so you can't be you can't be too risky
here and risk a two-point lead sometimes
because that's hard to come back from
even in in going back and forth when
you're going back and forth like this
one game i win game you win a game
the person that goes up to usually can
get that streak and that momentum and
that could be
over from there so it's definitely
detrimental bishop h3 is on the board oh
my goodness he says let's go for it
what is that god messing around bishop
h3
he's unpacked a lot of peace sacrifices
in this match so far bishop h3
well that pawn is loose and let's say
you take it yeah
takes yeah knight takes back king up to
g2
and then what i think i think it's just
takes bishop h4
oh hold on that's in there teddy's
strong
strong okay teddy that was nice pawn
takes knight takes kg2 snap on f2 snap
on f2 twice bishop h4
check and king f1 and then maybe queen
f6
oh my goodness that is gross exactly
this is the family
there are kids watching this one that's
gross
and if there are kids watching take note
of that tactic right there bishop h3
looks like a big time move uh now that
i'm looking at taking on h3
it looks lost so i'm looking at knight
takes e4
as like uh you know i just need to make
this move there it is yeah she goes
forward
she goes for it yeah and bishop takes g2
is the critical moment i'm assuming
has to be g2 and
knight takes g5 is well can you do that
and then play bishop g3
definitely can um i guess you just at
that point you you would just play
knight takes e2
and or bishop takes f1 one of those
moves bishop g4
does look like a a good move to at least
survive
um in this position there's no knight
takes e2 anymore there's no knight h3
right yeah there's no not h3 anymore
uh definitely loving black's position of
course here but white is having some
dynamic counter play with
knight g5 and bishop e6 coming in we
have some defenses
we do have some defenses where we are we
i think it's inevitable that exchange is
going to be lost but it figures out
we have to figure out kind of how what's
the best way to do that what's the best
way to actually give up this exchange
without losing too much
and playing inaccurate here because
black is already you know slightly
better here
especially with the eval bar going in
that way but these are humans here and
we have to try to figure this
out but there are chances though for
carissa but definitely uh
teddy's doing a great job he needs to
speed up though so the rook is hanging
um if bishop takes f1 bishop takes c8
for example
i i'm not so sure about that like queen
takes c8 and the queen gets into g4 i
thought teddy should just gone for it
there but
he really wants that material he wants
to take on f1 but i'm not convinced
after you take on f1 rook takes bishop
g3 for white
you got c5 coming in yeah that's great
counter play
compensation is some big compensation
here for white as
it's back to equal now rook pa he just
wanted to keep that material here and
there is bishop g3
and you kind of have to go for this the
bishop is looking crazy
you're not going to take on e4 so you
you literally have to take on f1 there's
like probably no other move
um yeah take on f1 and then what's the
follow-up but teddy is losing
critical time here critical time right
now he's down i mean 30 seconds here
basically it's not a
it's not that fun to be down this much
time messing up disadvantage here and
again he's down
he's down one game this could be the
second game which could you know lead to
decisive results in tilting yep and rook
beat e8 is a move that he's looking to
play as soon as possible
um there's also c5 ideas by carissa but
she's got to sort out this knight
problem first
knight's being attacked knight takes g5
obviously move rookie one
looks reasonable does have some
discovered attacks or
you could just go knight back but i
don't like necessarily allowing knight
e2 um yeah that's correct here huh
[Music]
it's a tough one very tough and she's
now yeah she
spent a long a lot of time here because
though this was a critic this is a
critical moment
and now the next hit again i mean rook
bde-8 is an easy move for teddy to play
in about two seconds
he makes the threat all over again yeah
yikes look at the time now it's
completely
flipped now it's under 20 seconds for
carissa can you just play rookie one
what's wrong with rookie one
well i guess it it looks like you're
almost walking into a pin but that
bishop on g3 is just holding it right
because i mean you gotta make a move
here she's out of time knight f2
and the time is switching and it
immediately jumps into black's favor so
what's the move here must be something
nasty here but i don't see it it's not
very clear
yeah i i'm looking at knight e2 as a
really strong move
h5 looks good because there's no e6 okay
snapping a bishop off
yeah and i think that's for clean h4
take on yeah taking two for you
i think she didn't want to or he didn't
want to allow rather bishop e6 it's just
one of those annoying looking moves
teddy's feeling it here he's seeing yeah
he's feeling it come on teddy he's
he's going to try to pull this one out
here queen takes g4 nice defense
king g2 yep there it is
i'm about to say a triple on the file
with a smile oh no
that probably can't be right snap okay
now tr
oh yikes gg oh bishop takes f2 is the
wrong one it had to be
broken um i mean the time taking down
playing the the best move under time
pressure and we're talking about
single seconds here is you know that's
just a difficult task
and that works for teddy in his favor so
now it's back to even so he can
sigh you know i can breathe okay it's
not a two-point lead
we're even now and now we can go back to
where we are and look at that he
switched it up
you see that good job good job teddy he
did not want to go back into
the king's indian and i have to say good
job because it's so hard
as a chess player you have your openings
you're stubborn you studied them
that's what you know best but for some
reason or another it's just not working
in a match
and to switch up this early on in the
match i think
that that's just the maturity yes that's
just the maturity there absolutely not
actually i love this position
already here did was did this start as a
job in london or something
it looks like yeah just just the london
moves and he switched it up and then he
switched
three right now we have a e4 on the
board here more of a
philadelphia modern type position almost
king zidion style still
as well i like white positions in here
just because of uh knight d2 knight c4
being a critical idea because the d6
square is extremely weak
yeah bishop e3 i mean d6 is is weak you
could even consider playing queen d6 in
some positions but
um very solid approach by teddy got h3
to stop knight g4
keep that bishop safe on e3 and you know
at some point you might see white throw
the a pawn up the board
um a45 looks like a
a decent start here also queen d3
um to c4 is another uh common maneuver
and we do see teddy
start with that a pawn yeah start with
that and this is actually a perk now
like or pierce is what they say we know
in america we say perk all the time so
they're going to kill me in the chat you
know yeah
it's pure it's pronounced beards right
you know but it's a it's a it's it is a
perk or appears here now and actually in
these positions knight c4 yeah
this is a pretty tight position it's
honestly still theory to say the least
so it's
equal chances for both sides not
familiar with the queen e1 lines i think
black is now
slightly better here because there's a
critical line that you actually have to
do to play this
correctly is why well you you're giving
a lot of credit there
by saying you're not familiar with the
queen e1 line i i don't know if it's
even a line at all
so that was very diplomatic of you there
i'm not familiar with this line
uh i don't know about a line but queenie
one is looking like the absolute
wrong energy all around yeah it's
usually not right
but i mean hey you know we could make it
work it's not that bad usually the queen
likes to sit on d2 and e2
those are the critical squares from uh
pure studies but
that's usually oh my yo wow this this is
why we came to play today like bishop
takes h3
this is why queen e1 is not a line this
is not a move right
that's not a line oh my goodness there's
no guys already there's tactics on the
board yes bishop takes h3
okay so take so i guess she's going to
take on h3 now with a critical
i mean pawn structure it's absolutely
h5 and white is in serious trouble
serious trouble absolutely gross
position for white now i would be
ashamed now um because i'm an e4 player
so i know when i play i'm e4 for life so
when i play e4
we get a pierce defense this is not what
i wanted
at all the furthest away from it when
you play the pierce defense
or against it knight h5 is an excellent
move followed by moves like f5 and even
trying to get a bishop on e5 after
kicking this knight
it's really annoying on c4 yeah like
knight h5
queen g5 knight f4 or queen h4 these are
all like game-winning tactics knight h5
is really important when we live
i mean even queen h4a like you said
queen g5 like
sometimes even having work lifts but
it's difficult to lift in here
we would love to get a rook lift in but
like that seems almost impossible
to do you don't actually need to though
c3 is hanging so like your queen has to
stay on e1
like man tough game here tough game but
at least it's dead even it's like
they're starting over
so okay you know take take stock don't
do this again
and then keep going forward just like
he's doing right he's not playing he
didn't play d4 or the king's indian no
more
this one's not working cool we're to
switch it up until we find something
that does work
is because they have so much time here
today uh i'm looking at like b5
uh you know take stakes and then b4
maybe if you really want to take
advantage of that pin
he goes uh or she goes rather different
direction with
uh bishop h6 oh yeah bishop h6 yeah
bishop a6 hitting f4 okay that can be
right but i mean
yeah my queen is getting in there like
queen g5 and we live
close you like it queen g5 the only
thing is you almost wish
your bishop could go to f4 and then
queen g5 so your bishop's actually
participating in the attack as well
very nice i like that bishop f4 first
and then
i like that i like it looks like the
order yeah my my idea actually was queen
g5 bishop f8 but
actually um that is the same thing it's
just better i like bishop f4 more
because it cuts off the h2 square
which is what i was going for that's why
we was playing bishop f8 to play bishop
uh oh actually no that doesn't well you
were setting it up the long way with you
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so bishop f4
though is
just more direct and then after queen
check we got knight g3 and gg
so that's like over yeah and keep in
mind
an important principle uh for the people
watching to understand is that
when you when you have a position with
opposite bishops and it's an end game we
always say that it's usually a draw
because
you know these bishops just never
intersect each other they they always
dodge each other on opposite colors but
when the queens are on the board and
there's an attack in full force
that means that if i'm attacking and i
have a dark square bishop
it's so hard for the other player to
defend because just like in an end game
they don't touch each other the same
thing happens when you're defending
all of a sudden your light squared
bishop can't defend anything that that
dark square bishop is attacking
yeah that's correct yeah it's actually a
um a good position for the person
attacking so opposite color bishops does
not mean it's a draw
it does mean though that they can't help
in the defense at all as you see the
bishop
on d3 is nothing but a pawn here it's a
big pawn tall pawn whatever you want to
call it here but it's not a piece right
now
so it's uh it's like you're playing down
a piece actually
black plays bishop g7 i guess just tying
the position down
so the interesting thing is that knight
on c4 is the glue
it's holding the position together you
move that knight bishop you're live and
you can
you can resign yeah so i like to move
rook b1
it gets out of the pin on this pawn and
it stops b5 most importantly
critical critical because b5 yeah that
that is the glue he says
that's 100 correct because 95 is
uh it's covering e5 the knight is
covering e5 that bishop check is
devastating
you might even have to play e5 in some
cases because you do have to defend it
but it's scary like this is all losing
but look at the evaluation bar like
that's very deceiving
looks are very deceiving like this is oh
it's equal
equal where equal what what kind of math
are you doing like that's
yeah and there's only a single move that
saves the position
to around an equal evaluation and
basically
all the moves were around stopping b5 so
rook b1 was a move
queen b1 was maybe a move as a
ridiculous like
uh queen g3 would be blundered there but
the point is if b5 happened to me the
game is
the game is like over right i don't see
why b5 is not crushing here
exactly yeah b5 is gg right i mean is
there an equal or stronger threat maybe
rook g1
i think i mean because that's why the
engine thing was minus three so yeah
it's got to be b5 yeah b5
rook g1 is probably g1 just like yeah
there it is just to throw it in
and i think queen f4 is reasonable
enough the knight's gonna end up there
there's like
bishop hanging nice hanging pawn right
actually yeah i wasn't into trading as
well because i like keeping pieces on
because
i'm just trying to mate you all the time
if i can keep yeah totally fair
you know i'm trying to make you i don't
want to trade anything
but yes uh trading would actually be an
easier win
technical win there as you said the
knight in the bishop's hanging the pawns
hanging on d3 and c3
i mean it's just an easy in-game win
there are no problems there bishop takes
c3 with bishop b5 and we live gg
everywhere all the diagonals are gross
for
for white especially the dark probably
the main thing in teddy's favor right
now
is you know there's there's ideas once
you save the rook queen f3
that knight is hanging on h5 and most
importantly the time situation he does
have like
almost an extra minute and you can never
underestimate what that does to carissa
she has to play that
that ever so much faster and she might
blunder in time pressure
yes correct the time pressure is is on
carissa yep has actually been showing
she hasn't uh
she hasn't crumbled pretty like it
wasn't drastic
mistakes she didn't make that one
mistake but they both did she you know
he hung the rook
or she hung the rook and then it was a
piece before that so it was just back
and forth generosity
but uh this definitely is a sharp play
as we have a 40 seconds for carissa
it is enough time as long as she just
keeps thinking here play easy moves
bishop e5
knight to g3 coming maybe rook c8
he's trying to actually uh i think he's
a fan of rook a6
um maybe the engine isn't a big fan but
it kind of stops black's pawns
and also eyeballs this pawn on g6 so i
think that's a good creative move and i
also like queen f3 may as well make that
threat of queen 88 might as well
yeah actually teddy's very tricky
slippery player very tricky as we've
seen him
sacking and doing all kinds of stuff
don't give it don't just give it to him
here queen f3 queen takes h5
is a possibility with it doesn't work
yet the queen is too
close on e7 for defense to be able to
sack everything on g6 but
you're thinking about it i was thinking
i was definitely that's the first thing
i'm thinking about
usually my second but if i it doesn't
work and especially e3's hanging as well
carissa yip is down so much time here
whoa
yeah that's pretty that's tough you
can't be down that much time now this is
definitely probably um
i mean maybe drawn or she might lose
this based off her time to be honest
absolutely queen takes e3 and needs to
be played very quickly by teddy a7 is
going to be hanging after that
queen h6 ideas look at teddy bounce back
here
look at teddy bounce back here so now we
just probably keep threats up what's the
best move
maybe rich g4 i really don't want to
play that yeah he plays it though but
i really didn't want to play that cool i
didn't want to trade really so now queen
h6
yeah queen h6 looks reasonable um as you
said
pressure is all on g6 right but the real
threat is
you know there's also rook h4 ideas um
quincy one yeah
knight p6 so she's like very scared
that was a great defense though yeah she
played knight b6 because that rook was
nasty i was trying to mate you
and she stops it no more mates now you
probably take on b5
i'm trying to uh well maybe i just take
on b5 why not she got two seconds on the
clock
queen a1 oh look at this look at look at
the change up here on us now
equal well bring the rook everything is
loose now f1
okay five eight seven five oh a7 is
hanging oh and as soon as rook f3
happens
rick f3 man should get right in there
rick f3 is that right guys there it is
it's on the board knight d7
how do you finish this off no moves he
hats knight d5 is is a huge move
coming up six seconds oh my goodness
look at him shaking his head okay six
check king h1 oh
thank you so much everything must go
sale and have a nice day
queen f6 yep that's over bishop takes g6
why not don't even think twice about it
give me everything
six wow gg man that was crazy
holy smokes wow teddy was not supposed
to win that game and i i should
like jump back to that game for just a
quick second there were a lot of tactics
that just
zoomed by at the end um because
yeah what was that first of all the main
tactic that i saw was after king g7
it looked like rook takes b6 yeah called
like queen a1
and rook takes 88. it was the first one
yeah yeah i saw sneak by there
yeah um and then after that
it was the knight f6 move by black which
was the the
the big mistake of the game and then the
game was over
after that so we'll get back to the
current game but man there were tactics
flying left right and center
carissa ends up uh the worst end of that
teddy takes the lead
the first time in this match i believe
three to two yeah that's correct and now
he feels i'm sure he feels great about
that game now
he's trying to close it out and then he
say close it out is in the no one's had
a two game league yet
sometimes and usually when you do have
that two-game lead
psychology for the player down to
usually kicks in as they're like i can't
lose another one and we're scoring down
three so you take
extra risk and it's just so many things
that happen one being down one game
is fine being down two games though is
definitely a huge
difference and you need to make sure
that we stop the bleeding to say the
least
in that sense queen to c7 is on the
board so what what was this opening
actually um it looks like so we'll just
refresh the moves um quickly so people
can see how we got here but
it looks like a very similar ready style
uh position
that we have seen in the past from
carissa so she usually takes these two
bishops and last time we saw this
opening
uh carissa expanded a little bit more on
the queen side and then there was a
bishop takes g3
um attacked so i think we might still
see an h5
by teddy if if carissa doesn't um you
know push the tempo in the center
right she play king g2 i think in this
or is this a live position um i believe
okay position for some reason i thought
i saw kinky too maybe that was
weird i literally saw her pg like
that was so weird bishop f4 that's why
we have canty in the commentary booth
he's living in the future and he's here
i've seen these games
i already saw king g2 bro i guess you
can see it
i didn't measure before queen d8
oh i could play e5 but is that correct
um
a little bit risky i i would probably
bring the queen back instinctively but
you thought definitely consideration
there
uh 97 yeah queen d8 we're back
now it's more like a philadelphia but
like a semi-sloth
but like they're five different
positions here it's definitely cramped
though
definitely crammed christian i'm a fan
of with these cramped positions
usually we like to chop off the bishop
with knight h5 or g5 very aggressive
yeah you need some space beautiful way
beautiful way to make some space here
from teddy
yeah so i mean the bishop is going to be
saved bishop g2
and i think all carissa needs to do is
go rook d1 and something like e4
and i'm pretty confident that she'll
have a better position here if you look
at teddy's king
going to the queen side makes no sense
with those pawns storming and going to
the king side
is so weak now that you've played g5 so
not liking teddy's position
he gave up the two bishops he's got a
very very weak light square especially
on f5
and i think that you know e4 at the
right moment by carissa
is is just going to blow the position
wide open for the bishop yeah you are
correct we actually can't even open a
position and you
man i mean like guys when you have
bishops on the board like this like
the worst thing you want to do you have
to play to the minor pieces you have and
having two bishops
absolutely i'm trying to open a game so
if e4 does happen we will have to
probably respond
with the move d4 which kind of sucks
because it's very weak
and we actually have to keep the game
closed as long as possible because we
have knights and those knights
as soon as you open a game it's a wrap
e4 happens the bishop gets to c3
that diagonal is monstrous it's uh it's
over actually if that does happen here
yeah and e4 d4 what that means is
eventually
you know white's going to save the
knight but then comes f4
and any e5 and those knights are going
to get lead around the board yeah
this is scary you see he's going down on
time here because this is critical
this is very critical here this could be
very decisive now he is up a game so
not that he can afford to lose a game
and he can but at the same time here
he wants to you know try to close this
i'll get that two-game lead that they're
looking for
from in both parties knight c4 and ricky
one is very nice
so i like rook a to d1 because i'm
expecting e4
opens up the e file and i expect that
looks to be necessary
i feel like carissa left the rook on a1
to deal with like a5 but it's
counterintuitive you almost don't want
to rook there so black can't
execute a trade at some point that's
correct yeah i like to have to work on
f1
and then playing f4 and also just like
keeping the rook ready to rook lift on
that file and look at that a5
does happen like immediately actually
too
yeah i think i think uh rook a to d1 was
maybe a little bit more precise but
still a big advantage here for carissa i
think that
um this taking on b4 business
is almost like it just doesn't matter i
i would just go e4 and just for anyway
you're just doing it i just don't care
about life i'm just going to play it
anyway
e4 he says because i i think the the
advantage that carissa had
has disappeared uh yeah disappeared
completely
yeah and actually the bishop's gone and
he has no worries anymore
even uh even playing moves like in this
position bishop's gross on e7 so we're
probably going to see rookie a bishop f8
and bishop to g7 also um when this
happens in many cases you're able to uh
even though the bishop's on g7
even though the light squares are
extremely weak for black you're okay
because the bishop's covering the dark
squares around the king so it won't be
it's going to be harder
to create an attack for white actually
after this maneuver here
exactly yeah this this is a still good
position for carissa i think she should
take it slow
um give up the idea of e4 because she
doesn't have two bishops anymore
maybe more like e3 knight e2 knight d4
try to use that f5 square great plan e3
92 94 i mean that's like that's
automatic you also have b5 but i don't
have to take i'm only getting the file
but i mean c6 would be weak but yeah oh
yeah c5 is any two yeah so you have to
play e3 92 knight d4
that's an excellent plan put that knight
planted on e on d4
try to get into f5 and work something
work the position
because you could try to combine both of
our plans like put the knight on d4
and then suddenly the b5 move might make
a lot more sense once you have a little
more
pressure on the c file right very good
very good here from both parties here i
mean actually chrissie i could have
played this better
there is e3 we're going to see bishop f8
most likely
and then 92 94. and there we go so how
about for black so we know that white
wants to play knight d4
maybe slide the queen to c2 get out of
knight d4 and prepare maybe b5
so how about from black's perspective
we've seen 94 come in bishop g7 probably
and do you take that knight on d4 do you
think is it that powerful
um that's a great question i would
probably wait
i would probably wait uh for a move or
two just to see if there's anything else
to do
and then i'm like okay we gotta snap
that uh you know at the right moment
here
queen f6 nice hitting f2 that's why
again look you know that rook if we
would have did it with the other rook
we wouldn't have to worry about f2 right
now
so this is kind of a funny position
because f3 traps the knight
but even though it traps the knight i
this is so i'm not i'm not sure that i
even like it
knight takes g3 knight g3 rook e3
and i got those dark squares yeah
they're kind of making me a little
concerned i think teddy's
got great compensation despite losing a
piece the eval bar actually thinks is
the same i mean they're like yeah you're
down a piece but you know white's only
up a pawn
right now yeah even though you've got a
piece for that so now we just if
the bishop gets active bishop d8 bishop
v7 bishop da bishop c7 that's way too
long
it feels like but if we are able to
activate that bishop on the dark square
diagonal
where he's extremely weak another
opposite color bishop in game
this is going to be this could be very
decisive it's it's a game to say the
least queen f4 looks
possible yeah queen of rolex possible
and let's point out it's
not insane here to trade queens that's
how good black's position
is like the pawn structure for white is
is completely shattered
the bishop on g2 is is no good
um queen g6 though keeping the queen's
on the board preparing maybe bishop to
g7 maybe doubling rooks we'll have to
see what uh
what his plan is maybe even f5
f5 yeah i actually i'm a fan of this
dynamicism here i like the p
sacrifice i mean it was involuntarily
like a b sacrifice so he didn't work
exactly he didn't want to sack the beast
he actually you could see in his face
like i can't believe i dropped this
piece right
but at the same time it's some good
counter play he's going to play on as we
should it's a great game still
more than good counter play i as soon as
i saw the sack i thought you know if
it's a blitz game i'm taking black ten
times out of ten
ten times out of ten yeah every time
yeah of course playing england gambit
stacking the queen
playing it against gm yeah beating them
online you know this is a privilege
yeah yeah it's a it's uh equal here two
zeros that's crazy
zeros so what is uh what do we do well
that should just give
you know maybe some of the chat a
perspective on to the position it's it's
two pawns for the piece but
the the compensation is so real that the
evaluation is
basically equal and usually if the
evaluation is even
but one side is down a piece you want to
be the side who's down a piece
because it usually means there's you
know enough tricky elements in the
position
and we see here this knight on g3 just
can't get involved
uh the dark squares like bishop d4 um
gonna gonna get that check in that
second rank you know what the character
wanna faruga game was very similar to
this where he he could have sacked on g2
fabiano could have sacked on g2 and had
um when i did the post game analysis for
it was like a similar position where
like every move
was just very bad even though he had the
extra pieces i think it was two
two-piece sacks something like that but
he was just a very bad position
and this is very similar work on a
seventh rank dark square is weak
white has three out of five pieces on
the back right here
and black is just coming all into the
position here rook a3 and uh
yeah this is okay two are okay three i
think at some point even eight
five h4 h4 yeah f5 f4 i mean yeah you
got
so many possibilities here look at all
the white's pieces on the back rank here
but it's a time scramble anything's
gonna happen
anything that's gonna happen here so my
opinion is that in a time scramble it
technically should benefit black
uh normally i would say that but um i
think
i think carissa is is just generally
happy to get a time scramble because the
position is so rough
that it's like you may as well take this
to a coin flip scenario yes correct 13
seconds 12 seconds for teddy here
so he shakes his head there's a check
you have to go king oh you got bistro
king h7 is kind of annoying we do have
the rick a3 move that helped right
because bishop d3 is no longer a threat
so she plays rook b3 it loses on the
spot oh he missed rook
a1 i think rook a1 was the move yikes
rookie when was the move here now he's
just down a piece you can you got you
got to be careful with how many trades
we do
d3 oh man that's right
i don't know if chris is gonna go for an
eight h5 but that's definitely playable
and
yeah she does she sees it monster here
trying to even out the score bishop d4
check oh yikes this is annoying yeah you
gotta trade now
and this is what i was saying though
don't be afraid to trade because yeah
i think it's still reasonable for black
all these extra pawns just like the
what game was that geary and um
yeah exactly versus a million pounds
and steel gotta draw monster
bishop check takes
knight d3 he's out he's activating the
king the king activation is great
brook g3 is nasty oh man oh yeah it was
checking we got to move
take 65 two seconds one second three f6
pre-moved removed
oh my goodness are they gonna take a
draw here
neither of them wants to lose no carissa
wants more he wants more look at teddy's
facial expressions bro
oh my god oh my goodness get the man off
the board
oh my goodness no he didn't yes he did
wow
teddy teddy just like he just looked up
to the man upstairs there he
reeled back in his chair a sigh of
relief i wish we had a heart rate
monitor on that game
hey man you know i'm not even playing
him i just got like my skin got all hot
just now
you know i'm like man i'm not even
playing i'm like whoa
that hit me i i felt that i felt every
part of that wow
and that was carissa's decision you know
and credit to her that's just the type
of
i think that's more of a young player
thing it's that fighting chess you just
never want to draw
that's just that feeling uh and she
wanted more
there was a repetition the players were
going back and forth same moves
and chess if you do that three times
that is a draw by repetition
she didn't want any part of that she
said look i'm gonna keep playing this
i'm up a piece
i know i'm gonna down like a bunch of
puns but i'm gonna keep trying and
unfortunately
she tried to her own demise and even
teddy that's
her loss there man comes away with the
checkmate with the checkmate victory
man i mean wow self-made there that was
like while in the time scramble you
never know what's going to happen there
and i think it is i guess something just
with the younger players here actually
uh
grandmaster hess actually said the same
thing about farouja in the game where he
was uh drawn
or it was supposed to be just a draw i
think he was playing uh niels or
something like that and he should have
taken the draw
and uh he was just trying to fight like
is he playing for a win like you're down
a freaking
you're down a poland like how are you
playing for a win here
right and it's and it was like no play
for a win but still wanted to play for a
win
and that's a very nice fighting spirit
to have never giving up but also it can
backfire
a lot i mean i've had you know have you
ever had that over the board where
you you played on and then
when you've played an entire game and
you feel like you've been winning for
most of it or you've been up material
for most of it
it's hard to be objective chess is an
objective game but it's so hard to
remove yourself
from the game and just look at it and be
like wait what's the position like now
doesn't matter what happened in the past
what's the evaluation now
and you probably know it's a draw but
your brain is saying hey man
we got to make up for the for earlier
when we mess this up you know get that
win but that's not the right mindset
that is correct here and actually i
think uh teddy now has that two-point
lead guys that two-point lead is
something serious when that two-point
league gets in there
psychology starts to kick in as a player
being down two games
now you're down two games back let's
let's not forget he brought the king's
indian
he brought it back he's like all right
i'm up two games let's try to figure
this out
maybe i can you know i can play my my
favorite like you said as we as all
chess
players we like we got our stuff we love
to play i'm sure he loves to play d4 and
playing against the kings indian has
probably thousands of games against it
and he's gonna play it again now i'm up
two games i'm going to play it a little
bit differently now
and i like the approach that he's taken
this time it looks much better
i don't see a clear attack i mean b5
looks very very tempting from black hair
but
and then he's actually thinking of
something here and he's his mind's blown
as he
yeah i don't know like i don't know what
he's thinking of right now right
he was like boom oh man like he's
thinking of something right now
i uh probably he's he's wondering why
he's about to play bishop takes c5 like
that's a very committal decision
but he he was looking like he's never
seen this position in his life what is
this
right that's what he said yeah um
pono d6 i actually like white's position
this is not the dynamic counter play i
would have in king's indian defense
all of my pieces are on the second
seventh and eighth ranks it's uh it's
not a fun position at all and king's
indian is always supposed to be fun
this does not feel fun by far knight d5
and we live
yeah yeah evan i mean this is ugly
knight f6 and queen h6 is a idea too if
i could if i could stop yeah okay never
mind
never mind yeah she stopped but that
that was the the idea if maybe like rook
b8 or something i think that's
definitely consideration for just
straight up knight
yeah taking queen h6 knight g5 rg1 f4
crushing
crashing c5 is hanging right now c5
and then um maybe just back up but d6 is
hanging but then knight c7 does that
work
exactly i think i think that works um
rook c5 if knight d6 as james was saying
the line i think just goes knight c7 and
followed by queen d6 or knight takes a8
yeah and actually bishop takes h3 as an
inner between move then there it might
be defending uh
the knight depending on how it looks
kind of weird not a lot counter play
stuff that you need and love in the
king's indian fence this stuff you'd
look for but
again white's just you know a better
position here white honestly should win
this game
but of course there's a lot of chess
left you know and we don't really know
what what's going to happen especially
in time scrambles
absolutely and if that pawn on e5 almost
disappears from the board
or somehow removes itself that bishop
comes alive everything changes in this
opening so
white has to be very cautious not to let
that bishop out because we've seen
teddy's king has been stranded in the
middle of nowhere with that bishop
active so
he's had that experience before but this
is his best king's indian game
we've seen so far he really really
adjusted well yeah he has to probably
keep this pace up if he's going to play
he needs to play in this manner here he
made the adjustments the necessary
adjustments that he needed to make here
and it seems like it's working for him
in this game here now we still have
about
five six minutes left in this one so we
will see
the time uh on the game clock has
expired
so this is a the last game of the five
plus one time control
so what that means is that carissa can
bring that momentum right back with a
win here
bring it within one game whereas teddy
can almost go into the break with the
most commanding lead of the match a plus
three score so this is really pivotal
for the whole match right now yes pretty
pivotal is
is correct i mean this is um two games
down you know
last game here and we're going into the
faster time controls as well
and then faster time controls usually
it's much harder to play these same
positions and you need to win let's say
she loses this game you know you would
have to win three more games now the
bullet portion is there
not sure who the favorite is yet in the
bullet um we have to see who that is
there
maybe teddy we have to see the ratings
and see things like that but
three games like when you get down more
than two games it's very very tough to
come back even two games is
is very hard here this is almost a must
win situation for chris
yeah rook a6 i like this move she
basically wants to take this pawn
but she'd rather take it with the rook
so she's saying look let me play rook
takes d6 i like to
pin that knight rather than take with
the knight and then suddenly there's
multiple pieces
started hanging on the d file i like
that a lot very nice counter play she
found there rick a6 now
the question is what does white do how
do you answer this move
and teddy's trying to figure whoa
there's an idea
wow there is an idea okay now what if we
take
the bishop so is the idea to check and
just take that
bishop followed by bishop takes b5 and
d7
yeah plant and just plant yeah and just
plant
yeah this knight on h3 is so gross like
you can't do anything with the other
rook that you would love to um
but it's coming it's coming now
especially after you take on c8 so you
might be
you might be okay now but we are far
away from doing anything
uh um active with this knight on h3 so
it really is down a piece still
when black has this is a terrible no no
d7 was not right i think he just
confused
uh the two moves because bishop b5 first
and then rook
six you throw in a4 right then you get
the ball
you get d7 anyway so you got everything
you wanted in the dream
story there now black is just up in
exchange
with a weak pawn on d7 and the knight
out of the game looking crazy on the
other side of civilization
so wow that this might actually turn
around uh quicker than we thought here
because
i think teddy just maybe mixed up the
moves in his head i'm not sure if this
is according to plan now still
great to have that pawn on d7 when you
have a pawn so far up the board
look at the amount of firepower that's
required just to hold it there um
yeah yeah you're right firepower just to
hold it there yeah
we have everything we have it's one to
spawn right here
now is i guess he didn't want to f7 is
hanging
right now so why are we taking that i
guess rook f8
i would probably just take this extra
pawn rook d6 looks
um quite annoying to me because that
looks like it's dropping yikes yeah what
do you do you probably have yeah
yeah you guys look at this night you
keep talking about the night the poor
guy is
he's not even a spec he's not even close
enough to take photos
yeah no photos for you bro yeah no i
mean
this guy's got a telescope to look at
the action over here this is gross
that's a gross night guys don't try that
at home and what do they say
at home guys right nights on the rim are
dim
or whatever else you want to call it the
rhymes with them but nights on the rim
you don't put them there i mean you if
you do usually you would have to within
two moves or so
move it back to the center so you have
some action because now coming back to
it
this is it's detrimental it's it's
decisive here at this point
he looks like he's going to take the two
rooks if ruth takes d7
absolutely i think making the two wrists
there take that queen d6
rook takes d7 um the idea that he's
preparing though
tricky uh is bishop takes d1 bishop b3
and queen g8 mate if you try to grab uh
grab the pawn with the rook
i still think that's the right way to
play but i think that's what he's up to
that's what he's up to absolutely i like
that yeah definitely he's staying in the
game here so now
well rick d5 i want to play ricky i will
try to get rick d5 to work in some cases
because you want to try to open up some
lines for that light square bishop
trying to get the bishop
to these d3 and so okay oh she goes for
it she goes for it all right we
i mean there's no other way to do this i
have to take the queen for two rounds
all right and she says look you just
don't have the coordination if that
knight imagine that it could just jump
into d5
or maybe white would be better who knows
yeah this would be
this that yeah you're right i would
definitely prefer white in that position
with that knight on d5 but
with it being like what is your route
how many move one two
three ali reza just did this in that
draw game i mean yeah
probably like eight times eight times
bro
and it was found to draw here but man
this night
like you kind of have to do what you
have to do here but the question is how
does black actually
crush like it's not that clear
but you do feel like black's better so i
think
knight d3 and then bishop d1 to b3
is the route and then and then your rook
kind of guards your knight
e6 that's very nice that's very crafty
bishop d1 bishop d
bishop b3 and i can tuck my king on a2
and and i'm chilling and we we we're
trying to win this one okay
i want to start with bishop d1 like
basically he's talking about lock it up
i want to lock your queen
down to that b pawn yeah that's bishop
d1 oh that was losing
immediately what's the move well
i think it's i don't know if it's like
you lose a piece immediately but
basically the queen to f2 and just start
to take all these pawns looks like it
yikes very passive knight i mean yeah
very passive
all right we're supposed to work f3
right just let it happen
though he's missing that palm
hanging on b3 i think he just noticed he
missed it too
yeah he's like what did i do like what
are you doing with me bishop takes b3
there we go back in the game rook c2 and
what do you do
oh my goodness whoa c is tilting
she dropped the queen no that was me wow
oh my goodness that's not a move on any
and every level guys
on any and every level wow just drop the
whole queen
and everything in between the ice
gene that's another one that's such a
heartbreaker
mm-hmm such a heartbreaker because
carissa had had hurts
made the comeback in that game so
beautifully
honestly so beautifully to come back
from that
tough opening and and then suddenly this
could have been
just a one game difference in the break
but instead the the gap has widened it
is now three-point lead
for teddy coleman as the end of the five
plus one portion uh james
i mean thoughts on the match so far i am
excited i mean i'm uh i got goosebumps
and like sweating in here like i'm
playing so you know
this is the type of chess that i love to
see every single day and this is why we
bring it to you guys
because we know you would enjoy it as
well here at the i am not a gm speed
chess championship
excited absolutely absolutely and i mean
at the expense
of one of these players you know our
enjoyment is always at the expense of
someone
unfortunately and in that game carissa
unfortunately
laundry for a whole queen just simply
overlooked what what move teddy played
obviously
she was seized that ten times out of ten
just didn't really notice what move he
played
and she was so focused on you know
converting that into a victory
but she's gonna have to focus right back
up and i think
it's a great time for a break for her
for us because
she needs the time to sort of recuperate
after that and come back stronger in a
three-minute portion so
james and myself will be back with the
commentary the three minute portion
after this break
so
and while we are very excited to bring
you guys the three minute portion
of this match right here we have to
remind people that the full
lineup of participants has been
announced for pogchamps three
you see some very big names there on the
list
um the likes of michelle carr i see
pokey name there
moist critical coming back again of
course ludwig
and some very interesting names from
outside of the streaming world
um although newcomer to streaming logic
is there
he's been playing a lot of chess and
rain wilson so i think
people are very excited to see join so
so many names to mention but
um the pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6
is coming up and
james i think that's going to be a very
very exciting tournament
what do you what do you expect from
pogchamps three more of the same from
the last editions
a little bit more the same and also some
of the betters xqc is getting
nice i mean he's working on his game so
people actually taking it serious then
you bringing more people into it
mr beast youtube legend is playing you
know you got logic a
uh a well-decorated rapper like this is
sweet man without all the
all the diversity we're bringing in the
chess here and it's here at chess.com i
mean it's great bro it's i'm
i'm excited for it so it's gonna be a
treat for you guys
yeah so don't forget about that box
champs three coming up um
you know that's that's what's what you
look forward to
next but right now we got the three
minute portion and i should say three
plus one
so in all these formats in chess.com
part of the iron on gm tournament
and the speed chest format there's
always that plus one second increment
and uh there's been a lot of flagging in
this match so far but
i feel like that plus one second is
hardly noticeable it's not even a thing
right that's one second especially when
there's so many things to think about on
the board you don't want to make a
mistake
you are in time trouble did i make the
right move oh i hung my queen right
that's just how it happens you know and
we've seen that here so
three one it's going to be much faster
chess a little bit more in inaccuracies
here from both sides
and we're going to see maybe what if
they like switch up the openings i'm
curious to see
what happens here you know i'm
definitely into like switching the game
plan up
when you get to three minutes and one
second anchorman or a faster time there
look at that charissa yeah
right right on playing b3 the larson
system
so switching up the game plan from b4
just just just
b3 this time double finchetto and just
play
even in a hippo type fashion well not
after knight f3 anymore we're just going
to stick with larson's system
so i actually had a problem with this
with the black pieces i literally spent
like two weeks studying against this
opening
now i'm fine i mean i put youtube videos
out on it now like i
beat this person this is great now but
man i was getting crushed
with this b3 system before how about you
yeah b3 uh just a great weapon for blitz
chess and now that we're down to the
three minute time control what you're
gonna see is i think the player's gonna
be a little bit more loose in their
openings
um they need to play a little bit faster
they need to be conscious of the the
difference
and the time control and already we see
the same system from teddy
it's like it doesn't matter what
charissa sets up he's he's going for
bishop g4
he's taking this knight on f3 he's
giving away the uh the bishop pair he's
going for the solid stuff and he's
incorporating h5 so it feels like he's
got a rinse and repeat strategy here you
know what actually you're correct and i
mean we've seen this like every game
with black
this is the same thing nothing really
different here but
he's going for the same setup h5 trying
to sack on g3
and now she's more accustomed to it
because she got sacked on before on g3
so she put the king on g2 this time
played h4 stopping the expansion of the
h5 pawn and honestly just consolidating
now we're probably going to play knight
d2 and e4
is probably white's plan in these cases
here and black on the other hand
i see castling queenside and g5
maybe even g5 immediately wow
that's very aggressive yeah he has to
make a decision because
there's the simple castle if you just
want to you know go back into the safe
style
g6 or there is the full send mentality
of your own castle
oh yeah e5 ideas oh yeah it's about to
get nasty here g5 knight g4 is rook g8s
and we greats it's very very good it's
going to be very very nice
here i love black's attack here white is
still trying to figure out what to do
we need to finish our development and
how does black actually black has
completed development
white is still down like two tempe in
that sense there and even three if you
want to count the rook on a1
it's uh pretty pretty rough c5 i do like
this move you got to do something
c5 she going for b4 what do you think
about that
i think it's not in time what about your
g5 like full send on the king's side g5
takes and then you know get that knight
into g4 or even just knight h7 knight
takes back
and you know what even almost you know
of course it might not have worked but i
was even thinking after g5 plea h4
and then after sacrifice i mean that's
too wild that's that might be a little
bit too much
but we're getting in there
we are going to get in there one way or
another same ideas
same ideas so i'm wondering if takes in
d5 is the option
because i mean that rook is hanging over
there and d5 is threatening d6
d5 e5 yeah i mean that that has to be a
possibility first off we eliminate one
of the attackers which is the knight
and then we play d5 and about to take
another attacker and play rook h1 yeah i
do not like this anymore
black's in a lot of trouble he probably
should have played like knight h7
yeah just take him push i would go i
would go e takes d5
and i think i'd be fairly happy in a
blitz game that at least my center is
fully intact
g5 is hanging you know i got knight e5
coming in
um and wow f5 five played
oh yes i take it i don't have to
understand but what if i
don't though what's his next move h4
scary maybe rick h1
he still has some real some real threats
yeah there's definitely a case for like
queen b3 strangely enough that pawn is
not
that easy to defend on e6 actually
you're right and knight f8 is not a nice
looking move wow you would think b5
would be
i mean good like india didn't like it
but it's not like it's terrible terrible
no no it's easy no it's definitely
definitely not a bad move i mean uh
chris has got to get her attack going
um so completely understandable but i
guess it's like when you see h4
you know that there are big threats in
one move when you see p5
i don't see the big threats right it's
like it just opens some files
you're right right takes
okay queen takes c6 being obvious so
then we play
e3 you gotta stop that maybe you could
play f3 if e3
okay i did not like that one really wow
now this this is more like um you know
maintains the uh
maintains the position because maybe
queen c6 is d5 go for a bunch of trades
and trade the queens off
so he's looking he's saying look rook
there h4
and you know good luck you're either
made me or i made you right
and actually white is definitely not
mating because especially the beautiful
move rick d's to ga
now we just moved a king over king d8
and we chilling in the center of the
board
you know even when you think about d5 i
think it's high time like
yeah you write d5 h4 is coming yeah i
think we need this move
it's there it's on the board d5 is there
and sacrifice material
nine takes d5 stacking on h8 or taking
the rook on h a
so we got a pawn and a rook for the two
pieces and then we play rook b1
and maybe rick be seven that's quick you
gotta be quick
knight takes d5 and bishop takes he just
delay the attack get rid of those two
rooks or at least one of them
and fight you know rook v1 rook d1
c6 there it is lots of attacks look at
the attacking chances carissa yip is
swinging back
just like that very nice very good i
like it that's a
gig deploying some great counter play
here sacrificing material
so now um yeah black's definitely on the
defense here rook b1 scary to me rook b1
followed by rick b7
now the knight can be very active on c5
but it's probably not enough to be
something decisive yet it's not even
close to the king and even if you take
on c5 i have queen g6 in many cases
question is what do you do about d5
right now though i have no idea i mean
this queen needs to be saved uh queen b5
queen a4
that's fine i mean just hit that pawn
that's that's all that
that looks like needs to be done queen
takes c5 rooks oh it can't even go rook
c1 oh there we go that was uh
between c5 was good yeah and now we can
go right see one yeah ooh look at these
pawns though carissa's down time oh
it's a time scramble oh man we got now
rubbing your hands together because you
don't know what you're about to see in
this
yeah time scramble time everyone's
strapped in hey put on your seatbelt
guys put on your seatbelt mine's over
all right let's see what happens queen
takes f5 and we live just take the point
it's free yeah we have five singing a
queen outside hanging a four-pack
is nice though there it is she found it
a second time gotta take on g3
rick h2 is real okay all right queen g3
oh gotta play queen h3
yeah knight d5 to e3 is a huge move
ooh check rick have one check what are
you looking at
okay is hanging as well e4 is hanging
i can run around king f2 king de1
f5 check check oh my goodness look at
this walk
oh wow g4 whoa that works
i guess almost rook f4 we need to put
rook f4 there
oh my goodness to lose this something's
wrong 65
yeah rick c5 queen takes e5 snap on g7
have a nice day
c7 7 yep c7 knight c8
five nice moves nice moves working five
is nice yeah three seconds on the clock
rook f8 work at f8
rook takes e5 oh oh there it is bam
tactics win games
tactics win games whoa careful though
is a good move oh my goodness what a
game king f6
you can catch 83 93 93
oh my god wow please
help me oh my goodness oh man nasty
stop it another blunder stop it please
in the christmas i can't take it anymore
oh my goodness and it's just that's the
one tactic you have to watch over by the
way even at the very end
when when the when the fork happened
maybe king f3 king e2 take the pawn on
d2 instead of going up the board maybe
there's still a chance there
of yeah knight in a pawn but wow oh man
i can't do i can't take it anymore now
that's four games here
she's on four games guys and here
psychologically you can even see it in
her face here
slightly that it's just she understands
geez like i'm you know i'm down
i'm down that was a tough game i was
doing pretty good
and now i'm down four games with you
know a lot of time left here but
we want to try to you know stop the
bleeding here we are down four games and
and that's story though that that really
has of the match like
you talk about good positions but not
getting the results that's carissa's uh
you know matching in nutshell right now
because she's playing very well
and she's putting herself in a position
to succeed
finding that d5 move in the last game so
necessary
to avoid getting mated on the spot and
teddy just
seems to be mr nerves of steel right now
and time pressure
he is cool i mean there are blenders
left and right so he is blundering but
he always seems to come out ahead so
he's making the second last blunder of
every game that's right it's all about
who makes that last blunder there and
man
it was uh definitely carissa yet ouch
it was crazy game this is what we came
to see though today
so i'm curious hey i'm taking on e5 what
you think about that knight takes c5
queen eight well no it doesn't work i
was thinking if knight takes queen h5
and then maybe rook the ones
and like you know just going for it
right you know okay long castle right
that's just my style there but h4
i'm not feeling i think just g4 and i'm
good yeah i think teddy is
looking at the the position and saying
look f4 is a real big issue i think he's
gonna go like knight g1
try to play bishop c492 cover the f4
square
and he doesn't need to take crazy risks
so far what's happened is he's played
pretty solid
and when there is a sacrifice that does
work he usually takes it
but otherwise he sort of sits back you
know almost waits to be
attacked he's like you know porcupine
you don't bother me i don't bother you
and uh yeah yeah that's right that's
right
he's prickly you know and then you see
these pawns they're very over extended
here
only covered by of course the pieces but
these over extended pawns
in in-game will be pretty tough but also
right now in the middle game we're going
to attack them just like bishop d3
knight c5 being a move attacking and
defending at
right right now he shook his head
immediately yeah he shook his head
immediately guys he's not feeling that
and knight bishop d3 was just a blunder
in a way
knight do three check and you know we
have a a great position to be honest
now we do we're getting rid of the light
square bishop which is the asset of the
disposition
yeah black's fine now this is a great
country
great game here so i like knight e7 um
because obviously knight f6 drops the
e pawn but also in 87 has the idea to
maybe go to g6 and play f4 in the future
or just knight c6 to watch over that
pawn again so
loving uh loving the way that carissa is
dealing with this opening
um trading queens makes perfect sense
even keeping the queens on
queen c4 if it's more your style totally
reasonable as well
actually yeah i would like queen c4 i do
like that move a lot because i'm not
trying to keep the queens on because
it's more
you just have more attacking chances and
if i want to attack you
ever i want to keep pieces more on the
board especially queens queen c4 was
pretty nice actually like that
but of course this trade does favor
black steel we got the bishops
open position we got to be here she
didn't want to deal with the move
knight a5 which is why she played the
move b6 right
then a5 is one of those funny looking
moves that hits the bishop hits your
pawn and
leaves you kind of uh blindsided so uh
deals with that and 97 looks like the
next plan
teddy's knights just have nowhere to go
yeah night night
okay it's not having a good night
not tonight okay that's crazy man
there's more where that came from
oh man right right oh man but uh
castling uh rick oh you can't play rook
d7 anyway i was thinking so yeah
what about king placement what are you
putting the king maybe king f7
uh i'm thinking king f7 although the
move f3 is making me
consider castling a lot more than king
f7
just because that file might get open
but okay now that i see this i think
king f7 is still fairly solid
yeah king of summer yeah king h2 yeah
definitely loving black's position we
got the open file and both bishops here
um what white should be looking to do is
trying to trade one of the knights for
the bishops but it's virtually
impossible
right now because we don't have squares
to even go to knight d3 we have to get
our knight off the back rank because
it's
pretty pretty tough honestly yeah yeah
and then and then
you know like knight g6 follows or king
f7 king e6
but knight d5 very aggressive saying
look i mean uh
e3 pawn is weak and we see this move now
my question is after knight d3
how do you how do you meet that you have
to go rook a to e
and then what's another thing after that
like e4
and if you take maybe take with the rook
and then try to take that pawn on e5
that's a great plan bro actually pushing
takes
i'm gonna have to yeah shoot he going
for it too yikes
yeah black this is kind of what black
didn't want i mean because white's
white's fighting back now this is a good
fight what about
f4 that's a weird looking i think it
might be
the best move because i'm looking at f
takes e and rook takes e and i'm saying
that's good for white so f4 i like your
move this looks necessary that's right
so now we keep it a little close but
that's what white wants in a way but we
still we can't
close position that we can't use the
knights in i mean that's the worst
position to be in
like yeah i have a closed position i got
the knights but i can't use them the way
i want to
you know bishop b7 and we can go to d5
oh rick d7 is a thing yeah
nice counter eddie he's working his
position and that's why bishop b5
to keep an eye on that i think generally
speaking here i mean you're not
upset trading that night that bishop
always watches the h4 pawn
the knight on b3 let's face it is so bad
here
rook g8 we're gonna see a5 from carissa
so far this has been honestly a master
class with the two bishops so
let's see if she can convert this game
uh she needs it
she needs it in this in this match
format because the three-minute portion
you know only has 30 minutes left in it
so she's got to start getting some wins
in
yeah she has to stop the bleeding here
we haven't seen a win from her in many
games here actually four games so
knight's coming to d5 you better be
right oh yeah there we go 92 93 95
very nice here very nice play from teddy
now it's a time scramble so we don't
know what's going to happen here
anything can happen right here
hold on guys anything can happen like
this
yeah oh first
okay yeah bishop before definitely yeah
can you have one good before there it is
great move there rook to d3 and probably
just snap it off
i think snap it off probably just snap
it off i think we take
that
uh flags oh i see what's happened she
dropped out of the
the zoom call on screen and
and she just disconnected she's straight
disconnected she's not in the zoom call
the camera is gone oh my goodness
there's there actually couldn't be
worse timing on that we were just like
there's a queen hang in some end game
positions
there's you know forgetting about the
time there's a disconnect it's like
what literally what else can go wrong as
a competitor
that this is such unfortunate
such an unfortunate series of events
because we were just praising this whole
game
and to disconnect right right when you
need to play that bishop c3 move
this is heartbreaking it is
heartbreaking it is heartbreaking i mean
probably knocking things off the table
i'm sure
at the chess bra family i've broken many
chairs and mice
that we use so you know i understand
that's
pretty it's a tough situation but
knowing the type of competitor
that teddy is i mean he's gonna be the
first to to
probably not want to take this point um
on the scoreboard
um knowing like what kind of sportsman
teddy is so
yeah we'll have to see how this gets uh
resolved by chess.com and hopefully we
first of all just get carissa back
in the call and get things set up again
as i think she's still
um she's still not there but yeah
knowing him i think he'll be the first
to say look i don't want to win a game
like that
you know even even though it's a
competitive match yeah that's how
even jordan said that today you know
when he won
yeah that's not the you know greatest
way to win of course the clock is a
piece though and that's the rules
so and that's a preferred win but it's
still a win there it's pretty tough it
is
it's on the board so it is seven to two
um
pending just getting uh carissa back on
the call
that's the most important thing so we
can uh continue this match here
teddy is just uh standing by and uh
james i mean we're we're just seeing a
kind of an unfortunate collapse by
carissa it seems like every game she has
not just chances to win but she might
even be winning um
all these games and uh quite unfortunate
that
that so many things have just knocked on
her way this match yeah it's pretty
tough to say you know pretty tough to
see but you know we have a lot more
where that came from today it's exciting
chess and hopefully
she can bounce back from what's happened
so far
right and uh i think what we're going to
try to do is sort out the
tech issues and make sure we can just
get carissa back on the call
so we can continue this match um and so
we're going to call
it uh the half time uh of the three
minute portion right now and i think we
were due to
to to have our halftime break anyway so
um we'll be back the rest of the three
minute portion we'll get carissa back on
the call
and get things sorted out so james canty
iii
and myself are gonna be back with
commentary right after this guys don't
go anywhere
and we are back thank you guys for
sticking around
and uh you know james i think i think
we've all done this before but carissa
just pulled the
classic yet unfortunate forgot to plug
in the laptop trick so i mean
it really really is too bad because
unfortunately that's something that that
she was in control of
and and you know that's her
responsibility and in
a match format like this that point is
going to count
towards teddy's score as it absolutely
should um
and we're just going to go straight into
the next game the match clock has been
set to reflect that
and we are in the next game it's seven
to two now for
teddy coleman in this match yeah seven
to two he's uh commanding leads so far
with the bullet portion coming up here
so
we're gonna have to have carissa
definitely come out out of the bag here
and find something
much stronger than what's been happening
today yeah it's just it's just been the
case of
you know like a series of unfortunate
events uh
that's just the only way to put it
because carissa has
every opportunity to get back in this
match you know as soon as one of these
games goes her way they could all start
rolling her in her direction because
teddy has played a fantastic match but
carissa has has had chances to win in
probably almost every single game every
game yeah every game it was something
different there they getting in time
troubled and in time scrambles and the
time scrambles uh
usually actually they've been favoring
teddy as we've seen here so
we see like he just holds a little bit
better under pressure there and uh it's
pretty tough
to see here so she's gonna have to speed
up a little bit i think but not
and it can be inaccurate while doing so
so we're down the same line also with
the queen a3
i forgot where the queen was last time
it must it was like on d1 or something
maybe well we saw the uh we saw the line
queen a4
um with the knight on b5 and then um you
know the queen going to b4
to hit that d-pawn queen b8 was was
forced as a response
and then a5 to kick the queen back so
totally different
style here because as you mentioned the
queen was on d1 before and white was
just expanding with the pawns
this looks like you know both queens all
all uh
you know shoved way over on the queen
side there teddy is saying look
forget that queen side stuff um you know
let's defend this uh
this d-pawn and maybe go back to this
bishop g5 plan
actually yeah that is um that is some
especially called
theory that is correct bishop g5 and
also weirdly enough bishop h4 sometimes
it's a very really weird move but
bishop h4 in some some lines you were
able to do this but the bishop g5 is
excellent
trading off the dark square bishop and
coming in with knight f4 and again even
having f4 as a move we're moving the
knight and moving it into h4 and playing
g5 g4
in many cases here i do like black's
position white's queen is out of play
over there especially after this b6 move
great move from teddy
stopping the c5 potential from ever
happening
exactly um definitely i mean i would
give a lot of consideration to
moves around the king like just bishop
f1 maybe tucking it away bishop f2 as
well
um b4 takes takes hits the the pawn on
b6
and that that could start to mobilize
things a little bit on the queen side
uh but carissa is faced with you know
pretty obvious idea that that teddy
wants to play this bishop g5 idea
at some point you know he's going to try
to trade off the star square bishops and
all these dark square pawns are giving
him really good dark square control
something to be careful of if you lose
this bishop on e3 and you know what i
think after bishop g5
if there's bishop f2 then you play
bishop h4
if they go back to e3 then you play f4
and you're able to play bishop g3 and
queen h4
in many cases i remember seeing some
attacking stuff like that
and it's it's pretty scary how that
attack looks
it could definitely be a possibility
here let's see what happens
good idea to keep in mind f4 bishop h4
bishop g3 with the queen coming out and
you're saying
you know um don't care what's happening
on the queen side it's all about the
king and it's about checkmate ending the
game
absolutely check made into the game
right but of course we do have to worry
about that d6 pawn like as you mentioned
so he plays knight h4 i like it with the
idea f4 g5 and we live
king h8 rook g8 going crazy yeah that's
going to be scary now f4
always gives up the e4 square to the
knight so in chess there's always a give
and take it's not like black
you know just gets a free attack from
nothing so of course that is going to
come with its own concessions and it's
just whether whether or not black is in
time and that comes down to calculation
i think we did see f4 last time
something like that i don't know if f4
happened
is f4 even a possibility there
uh from white you mean or yeah from
white actually yeah from just stopping
f4 it's a concession in a way but right
it also opens up some lines maybe we try
to get the knight order bishop to d4
actually and then stopping f4 from black
almost for good
yeah that seems pretty reasonable
actually um
interesting yeah so now i'm looking at
c5 and i'm i'm almost playing that
immediately here
he's not even thinking about it yeah not
even thinking about that move bro
c5 i'm not even thinking about it yeah
that looks super strong
right now brooke g6 uh i'm looking at
bishop f1 and i feel like i'm holding
everything together
yeah he's pretty good as black here
probably f4 rick h6 like you got to go
for this now
teddy i don't know what he's thinking he
played rook g6 yeah i didn't like it
f4 at least hit something and then rook
h6
trying to give me sack like you feel
like you're here because it
they're going to she's going to fix it
figure this out on the queen side if
you're not
you know accurate here yeah c5 is real
crushing move rook into b7 or rook to b6
hitting the d6 pawn both look strong and
you have to ask yourself like
where is the the crushing blow on the
king side
like bishop f4 and queen g5 maybe just
all in
i like that i do like that i like and
actually bishop f4 rook h6
knight takes f3 and many cases there i
like e4 queen e5 yeah
and trying to sack on f3 when you get
that rook on h6 f3 sack is
potential it just has to be right you
got to line it up queen e5 bishop
f4 like you mentioned which is really
nice so
i see a nasty attack for teddy but he is
in time yeah
and look at teddy i mean he he has these
games where you feel like he's so solid
and then he has these games like this
where his position is going to fall
apart if he doesn't find checkmate
right right yeah here is this i guess a
miss
move order here because he definitely
had a huge advantage
of course the engine loves why here but
this is not an equal position but you
will say that black is definitely
fighting for mate here
yeah but now it's back down to equal
here i love it that's that's just the
nature of a tumultuous attacking
position
like we have on the board and all of a
sudden in just two moves
it's just you can't do that you can't
get away with that
like there's no possible way you're
going to be able to take this bishop on
d7 and get away with it
i'm thinking what bishop at bishop c1
the queen
is the nasty one it just forks the rooks
oh my goodness queen g4
yeah it's a really funny looking yeah
look at the simple move here guys i mean
when does that ever happen
look at the geometry there yeah i
understand what he's doing why did you
do that though
what are you doing with your life here
oh my goodness
oh my goodness that was gross that was
so bad wow yeah kenti has no what the
bishop's hanging
i am oh man look hey let's get this off
the screen stream's over y'all sorry
sorry we're gonna have to come back
tomorrow what oh my goodness
what was that oh my goodness
wow wow
yeah let's just go to the next game go
next thing we're going to talk about
that
we don't even talk about that that's a
bad word okay
wow okay so that game i mean you saw the
evaluation bar
knight takes g2 was the only move you
couldn't do actually you couldn't do
that one first you had to do anything
else right queen g4 like you said
was forking the rooks that was gg and it
was just crazy it looked like pogchamps
out there
you know it was uh in the end
carissa you could say she got that win
whatever way she got it
messy you know uh in in
incorrect moves left right and center
who knows who cares
if you're in the carissa camp you're
saying look i'm back on the on the board
here i made up
that that disconnection let's go yeah
you know and that might be
exactly the energy that she needs to get
right back in this match
oh yeah you know i understand if i win
if i beat hikaru right
king and pawn right i got a king of pawn
he got every one of his pieces
and he flags guess what i'm framing it
i'm framing it
you know i'm letting everybody know yeah
i beat him yep i did
i did did did he win no he didn't right
so okay i won i won absolutely every
single time and that's exactly
where she is here we'll take it we will
take it you know
a dub is a dub okay i know how it
doesn't matter
you know the clock is a piece too so and
we're gonna take what on earth do we
have in this game i'm just gonna quickly
play through these again
because uh we actually see carissa going
e6 97 and
completely uh unorthodox she is just uh
you know
bombarding the center with c5 with
e6 d5 and i i like it already
that's right i love it i love it for
black here open lines for the bishops
now i think
i would uh i think and even evaluation
state says
is equal to preferably black here i do
like black's position slightly better
but i think white's doing quite fine
they do have like h5 is
always going to be annoying and uh maybe
trading but if you trade tonight
that bishop becomes nasty on g7 so you
got to be careful
yeah black's definitely a fake h6 here i
if white plays h6 you're just you're
lost
basically uh so you can't let that
happen
h6 is neat yeah actually you were right
yeah yes that's over with oh he has
bishop h8 now
and it also closes the file yes that's
this is another way to do it um i still
think h6 is probably good because
you know there's just going to be some
attacking uh motifs to worry about here
but still
castling by black nice way to solve that
problem as well
yeah actually here i mean this is uh not
that it doesn't look that good for white
so what i'm doing is i'm just going all
out i mean actually i do that any
every game no matter how it looks i'm
trying to go out all out
castle queen side miss of a6 and go from
eight
sack segment bobby fischer but i'm
saying d4
d4 d3 by black looks oh that's annoying
that's real annoying right there d4 i
got to go 94 you play d3
i have to play bishop d1 that's gross do
i have an in-between move like
can i play knight f6 i think i think yes
yeah i think link knight f6 is a great
move and then you open up the ac
file as well yeah yeah so i might have
to temper myself d4 and 84
i probably need another move there i
don't know if it's f6 i don't know what
it is
oh you can't move tonight yeah but f6
right that seems pretty strong actually
f6 kind of annoying bishop h6 crazy line
queen c7 rook c1 man king's in the
center
yeah he's still not playing knight f3
for obvious reasons we just don't want
to open that bishop so you're
still trying to go d4 d4
you can't take that yikes i mean look at
her piece play beautiful got the queen
out of the pin here
the knights look beautiful there
covering 16 squares
total actually yeah yeah so this is uh
beautiful nights the bishops are backing
them great play come on
all right all right hey y'all wait wait
candy i gotta ask
you and your hat is that a move let me
let me get closer to the camera you see
that right there you see the hat that's
it that's not a move
knight d5 look i mean the development's
not there the king cannot castle either
direction
both central files are open on the king
i mean this
is this looks like just no you just
can't do this don't try this at home
don't try this at home okay do not take
it upon on d5
like that oh my goodness i mean so
just to let people know she gave up that
rook on purpose right so she wanted to
go rook d8 so bad
she says look take me on d8 i'm gonna
take back knight d4
now looks great and just all these
pieces flow flow flow
they come in with tempo yeah this is
flowing right flowing flowing flowing i
mean
of course like you still have to finish
development guys we are still in uh
fayette students as phases of the game
and the phase one is development
have we finished our development here
the kings on f1 the rook's still on h1
now it's pretty active but
it's not doing anything and the knights
on g1 so okay we're trying to fight as
much as we can and actually the
evaluation bar
is in white's favor now she messed this
up huh
yeah yeah i'm crazy the sacrifice i
think a computer is probably
always going to look at and say you know
i'm not a big fan of that
we could have done that better but when
when you think about just the human
perspective
i think the chances yeah yeah i think
it's still really really reasonable for
carissa
i i like where this is trending that's
true actually yeah of course that you
put that uh england gamut queen sack and
an engine and they hate it
but you you you're beating like me we've
seen it done you beat gm's with
it so it does it's all about the you
know how it feels when you're sitting at
the board or you're sitting at the
computer
playing against it and if you can find a
way out then
then it's might be not so good but if
it's difficult to play that's exactly
what a good sacrifice will do to you
yeah great sacrifice right you know many
times so yeah actually knight of three
is now on the board here
he's he's trying to do can you play
knight g4
knight g4 looks interesting i'm also
saying look if i just
take like knight takes on f3 or or just
take this pawn first i'm saying look
you can't mate me down the h file queen
h7 check is as far as you're going i go
king f8 i'm safe
and the king on f1 is not that
impressive so again i
i'm kind of liking what what karissa's
done here and and hang on there's
definitely
oh wait a second yeah knight takes e2
hidden c1
knight the knights hanging knight d3 is
that the move that might be the only
move i don't know i mean you got we got
a lot of pieces hanging here okay rookie
a lot of pieces hanging a lot of stuff
hanging here guys
uh rook takes d2 rook d2
you can't take on e5 whoa this is scary
no mates i don't see nothing dang that
bishop is uh queen takes b2 oh just take
the queen
yeah that's a blender just take the
queen brook d1 looks good
c6 looks bad that was very bad yeah c5
is coming behind it now you gotta
do something okay sorry there's four
seconds on the clock here
yeah i think reasonably speaking this is
probably a draw but
um it'll come down to somebody's mistake
in time pressure i think yeah somebody's
gonna flag some or
or drop something like we've seen before
that queen it happens man at time
scrambles are the hardest part of chess
we say
is when you get this low on time and
trying to stay accurate
and not blunder this is very very hard
to do guys
extremely hard okay double hold up
double on the bubble rook takes rook b7
rook b7 big fella let's go come on come
on work b7 that works no way to stop me
that works too oh my goodness he's
finding the moves hit him
oh man this is gross king c6 is just
that's that's uh that's a classy classic
oh
he stepped out of the way for the checks
i got it yeah i got it
that's a meaty one oh my bro
what rook va has checked me that he was
setting up the whole thing
almost now he's dropping a pawn on g2
i'm shedding tears right now what
i'm crying this is incredible this is
this is i don't even want to say nothing
it's a draw okay nobody lost
all right whatever i mean this is
ridiculous here it happens wow
time scrambles okay you gotta remember
guys it's time scrambles
so in time scrambles you're you don't
know what's gonna happen
you may think he was up a queen and then
you're not that's how it happens
every single time every single time miss
mayton
won one move game over
yeah and guys this is not a pre-recorded
segment uh
trailer for pogchamps iv this is this is
we're actually live right now
promising live this is probably that
wow that that is a big time miss because
it looked like he was setting that up
for the checkmate like this i mean the
intricate king c6 like the way he wrote
that
great it was excellent it was excellent
check move it over
and i was like oh he got it he set it up
and then dropped it
you know wow just like wow
man and it's been in every direction so
right now like the last couple games
it has to be said that it's looking a
little shakier and shakier for teddy
like
he has his his moments where you think
he's set it up and then he misses that
at the end
that's reminiscent of what's been
happening to carissa this whole match
yes yes actually she uh dropped the
queen there and didn't have
problems with the connection there and
dropping games here she's still down the
four point so it hasn't increased
so that's good in a way we have kind of
stopped the bleeding she
um as she should look at it that way hey
you know what cool
we're down four games but let's not
increase it anymore let's get this back
and really just focus
and actually cargo has a great statement
about losses and things like that you
have to have a short-term memory loss
and
in things like this like big events and
playing over the board chess
you have to have a short-term memory
loss when it comes to losses like this
because you can take all this into the
next games and you're not seeing your
missing mates you're hanging queens
and not playing like your real self
because you are still held on those
losses
yep no that's a great piece of advice
for
you know pretty much any competitor i
would say but especially valuable in
chess and especially valuable in blitz
chess because there are so many there's
a high volume of games that
you know being able to forget those
losses is exactly what you want to do
memory of a goldfish
yeah maybe we have a goldfish yeah
teddy bishop c4 just played and i'm kind
of liking what chris is doing i like the
f4 move
you can go g3 stabilize there you got
great control of d5
but i think we are you know more or less
in like a theoretical position here
i think um yeah i like this for well i
think it's
dynamically equal but i really like
white just because of the control i
think we have more control here
but those bishops are monsters i mean
that's some compensation for real
you open the game the wrong moment
that's lights out absolutely lights out
with the pawns together like even taking
on e5 would be a huge blunder like just
having both the pawns and the bishops
being able to swipe the board right king
h8 happening or ga
so you kind of have to even opt in for
g3 there it is king h8 rook g8
and we great i mean how many times have
we said that today putting this real
quick well there's been so many
attacking games that
you know we've been able to use the
catchphrase right look at that man
richie hayden be great it's awesome
queen h4
and i don't even care about the d6 pawn
um
being weak because you can't i remember
studying the stressing off theory
and it was even knight orbs too but you
learned that
there's two things you can't do you
can't do both as white you can't attack
the d6 pawn and control the d5 square
so you're either going to do one or the
other and if you're controlling d5
square
what i'm going to do is just play around
it and try to go for other things
because you're not doing anything
from there but if you try to take the d6
pawn then you're going to have to move
the knight from d5
which costs time so let's see how she
plays point or top teddy plays this
yeah now taking here that's to take the
f5 pawn
and knight takes e5 play because look if
you take with the pawn
it seemed like knight takes f5 was just
in the position of free pawn for the
taking so knight takes e5 hits the
bishop on c4
bishop b3 forced back um from carissa
and now
knight takes f5 that is the threat what
are you gonna do about that i was just
thinking that what is the move like we
have active pieces now i really like
white's position i mean it's active
it's activity activity what is uh gary
kasparov says uh
activity will trump material most times
so activity looks really good here for
white
active pieces rook f4 doubling right we
got a lot of stuff here and
the d5 square is definitely helping us
we would love to have a queen on h4 as
black
but i mean we can't do anything really
as you see teddy's going down on time
trying to figure this thing out
queen yeah the rook is going to slide
over to e1 in general the king to h1
move
is is one that i'm always looking to get
in the position um
and chris says look i want to solidify
the d5 square you talked about putting
pressure on d6 or controlling d5
i think it's pretty clear which one
she's doing right yeah it's pretty clear
we don't care about that d6 pawn we're
just going to stay on d5 and stay live
king h1 out of the way
that's automatically cannot stay there
like you just can't yeah it's also
threatening bishop takes d5
winning material right now yeah a little
bit too long here to be honest king h1
is like automatic here
thinking a little bit too long even
though teddy's down on time you want to
use this to your advantage maybe
what else could she be calculating i
honestly don't know
seems scary that seems like too much on
that yeah rook d4 is the
only other move i can think of unless
unless she's missing bishop d5 as a
threat
and thinks like you know i don't have to
do anything because that f4 is covered
like
and even f4 is a threat honestly okay
there is the king age one
there it is knight f4 oh there's some c2
c2 and wood and she's ready for that
okay she was ready she was calculating
what to do after that
now knight takes f4 can you do that
maybe not if knight takes queen takes e3
knight g6
then we can perpetuate the very least so
knight takes queen takes
man we in there bro that's in there
knight takes f4 you mean
and i takes f4 knight g6 yeah knight
takes f4 queen takes c3 brook takes f4
and then queen takes e3 though
that's quite a good cause because you're
right if you get that knight g6 and
that's
you really are in there yeah so maybe 97
um but you're still sacking the knight
okay yeah 97 now now 94
your first idea the the knight's not
hanging right and
i think this is great nice great job
carissa swinging
she's looking back here she's swinging
like i'm not going down like that
queen night five coming in like save the
queen queen h4
knight f5 hitting each six
queen h4 teddy's down to 20 seconds
under 27. i think he's gonna take on c3
yeah i was trying to say anything yeah
you got to take that and that's just
crushing but what's the move
it's not that clear no not that clear at
all
um i mean knight f5 drops the bishop
it's hidden right now
like she he's getting destroyed it went
from plus 10
to plus one like i think rook takes e6
rook takes h6
and it was lights out last turn oh
that's nice you're right you're right
yeah that's it and i think
i think he might have noticed that but
she did my goodness
sevens mate bishop g6 such a good move
wow can i take it dang oh my goodness
she gotta move yeah queen h1 snap snap
okay these knights are
barely being held together wow held on
by a thread here all right guys hold on
to your seat belts here you know what
happens in the time scrambles
you know what happened goodness time
scrambles i don't know what's about to
happen
at all oh that that doesn't work it
doesn't work
what is going on right now that is not a
move oh my goodness
that's over
i have never seen a mouse slip like that
like that
that is something else just breathe
that is something out that is a
basically you're you're so
in that time scramble moment that you
just played with brook takes f2
and you haven't even let go of the piece
yet yeah when you're trying to drag your
mouse over to each
other yeah yeah i think she i think she
considered rookie one
and that's why but she did work at three
so what was it was a slip it was just
i think the most was literally still
grabbing the rook and she was like
just trying to move over yeah to the h3
square yikes
oh man man just tough pre-moves here
guys like
five games i mean just unfortunate
events today as you mentioned today
like unfortunate events today for
carissa here yeah
it almost speaks to somebody who might
not be
like it speaks to a very strong player
who might not be used to the online
format
but the strange thing is that's not
carissa like she plays online all the
time she's so used to the format she
she plays bliss she does puzzle rush
like she's very competitive online
so to see her like have these mouse
issues or spots of blindness missing
free queens stuff like that
is very out of character yeah i think
it's uh there's many quotes to this
actually from boxing if people are
familiar with mike tyson they say
you always have a plan until you get hit
in the face and that's exactly what uh
sometimes it becomes that and psychology
part even in in boxing like when you get
hit and you get stunned or
it's just like oh i'm shaking a little
bit being down so many games here
is psychology part and even gary
kasparov talks about that part the
psychology part of chess is sometimes
even bigger
than the moves itself so here it could
be a lot of that it could be a lot of
psychology being down
and these positions are tough and then
i'm getting in time trouble and it's
more thinking about everything else
than it is about the game yeah yeah no
that's a
there's a lot of outside factors you
know there's a lot more than just chess
going on in this match right here and
carissa i mean we look at the game clock
and there's you know four and a half
minutes left
so it looks like this is favorite
to be the last game but um
but you know we have seen quicker games
so it just really depends
how quickly uh these players are going
to play this one out but this could very
well be the last game
in this three-minute portrait in this
three-minute portion yeah with uh teddy
being up
five games here a commanding lead going
into the bullet section so who do you
think's if
well uh i don't know who's a favorite in
bullet i'm going to put my
prediction out there i don't know i am
rooting for carissa in the bullet there
to grab some games there
because these time scrambles it's
honestly anybody's bet there but you got
to be a little bit we get they have to
be a little bit more accurate than what
we've seen so far in the bullet sections
yeah no i in the bullet i mean we have
everything to
to look forward to and just as a
commentator i'm rooting for
carissa to bring this match close so
that we can have an exciting finish
rather than have one player run away
with it as is probably going to be my
answer every single time
yeah but uh but we'll have to see teddy
is for sure
solid and he's been getting the upper
hand in most of these time scrambles you
know whether it's been clean or not
he that's where he's gotten a lot of his
points this match that's right actually
his time scrambles and he's came very
close there having good positions even
winning
when he was not supposed to at all which
actually psychology borrowed there i
would keep playing on no matter what now
because i know
that like you know if i'm losing all the
time and time scrambles and you kind of
know what to expect but
if i'm like hey it's up in the air down
the queen i'm still winning like
okay yeah you may as well may as well
play them on it we gotta play them on
we've got a pretty unique position here
in this one the brooks have just
disappeared from the h file
um carissa has a hard time castling here
to match
teddy because the the bishop just can't
develop that easily
like you want to play bishop v6 hit the
queen maybe but b7 pawn is just loose
definitely hanging and now the d files
open did not like that decision because
now you can't you still can't move the
bishop
or you still can't you know you can you
play b6 but that does weaken many
squares
and the d file is open c6
that's usually a good structure c6 and
e5 is kind of an annoying structure
it really is as an e4 player i hate
playing against that structure a lot
because of the center control it does
even though it's not in the center
but it is in the center like it's not
yeah if you look at the bishop
on c4 and the knight on a3 neither of
them can really access these important
squares
the knight on a3 is just sad it's really
annoying it's a very good move by the
way so
very annoying just so you guys know if
you ever want to have a nice structure
like that
pawns on c6 and e5 are very nice in the
philidor
the pierce type defenses and things like
that very annoying
so knight to c2 we had to kind of do
that and
yeah he needs to get the knight in the
game somehow queen eight three or queen
a2
he's gonna be two yeah he played b4 but
this is ugly i just don't have any
squares like man chris is doing a great
job restricting you tonight
one thing carissa has done well uh this
whole match actually got to give her
credit is the bishop pair i think she's
utilized the bishop here so well
in fact the game she disconnected sadly
was a bishop hair game that's why she
was executing super well
yeah she's doing very good very good
here the bishop pair is awesome she does
castle queen side now
there is knight before assuming a6 but
you still don't have a clear plan
like it's just c6 and e5 oh now okay
that that that i'm feeling great about
is white the e5 pawn's gone
we good we're good appreciate it like
thanks right
and that's so i think you maybe have to
take that but that knight c2 knight d4
can always come in and
suddenly suddenly you're right back in
there hey so what is it
what is it amman that was not a move
obviously and the engine went crazy what
you thinking
well knight c5 and like take bishop e6
and like some sort of take and queen f7
it's it's getting close to
to winning so i'm taking like queen g8
queen f7
it's almost winning on the spot i almost
sacked too i almost sacked on d7 but
then i was like well we do have bishop
e6 first so
that's better oh beautiful play here
from teddy yikes man
the thing is look at this structure from
teddy it's so solid and meanwhile
black's position is falling apart
so she's really yeah really strong
it looks like you can stack on c3 guys
but the intention is actually after
captures you play knight c2
and it defends everything and we're up a
piece no more checks actually either
we cover all the checks as well so you
got to be very careful here rook
d7 is scary because you do have to keep
the back rank on there there it is
it's kind of the last shot here takes
knight c2 and now we have uh
uh really checks and barrages of checks
rick d's
i mean uh maybe not yeah rook d7 rook h1
at least stays alive yeah uh queen takes
a
five he just takes a point yeah so i i
think king a8 rook b8 is the correct way
to try
um still of course shouldn't work but d4
is okay
yeah queen d4 defend everything yeah
defend everything this is a time
scramble so i don't know who's going to
win this it should be
it should be right it should be teddy
what we're going to see here guys it's a
time scramble
and teddy should win this but we're not
that sure
charis is playing some tricky moves and
vertigate's a threat
yeah ricky it's a real threat king you
two i'm out of the way rook the eight oh
my goodness oh you gotta play nike
she missed it she missed the mate
it was right oh my goodness everything i
wanted in life you gave it to me
and it was not i couldn't finish oh
man bro queen d2 is made
in one and she tried to play on for the
win
and she had to win and now it's no more
win she got a draw though
i think she wanted it you got two
seconds she got yeah she gonna take the
draw
no she she's two man she never takes a
draw i mean she don't believe in it this
might work out for her though
this might work out rookie two is greedy
five queen d3
game over queen d3 i'm out the way how
is it
oh my goodness teddy's mad i'll be mad
too
if there's one person who who deserved
you know some good fortune in this match
it was probably carissa after everything
she
you know we said it before it lives by
the sword dies by the sword
and the sword is her being that's that
stubborn that young
talented stubborn player you always want
to win you don't want to draw
this game she missed her chances for
meeting one but when the draw was on the
table she said
no i'm not having this again i need to
get back in the match
what do you make of things so far as we
head into the break
amazing i think it was crazy but we'll
be back after this so
yeah stay with us guys
and we are going to get into the bullet
portion very very soon but first want to
remind you guys about some things
upcoming first of all the
uh world corporate chess championship
that's right the first uh ever that i
know of world
corporate chess championship coming to
the feed day online so it's an official
feed
event it's gonna be happening online and
that is gonna be taking place
in february so mark the dates on your
calendar uh you know james i was
thinking about maybe uh the chess bras
uh you know myself eric uh you know
getting involved and just cleaning up
the corporate championship what do you
think i'm with it actually add me on
that uh squad as well absolutely i'll
sign the chess brought paperwork when
y'all send it over
and uh yeah let's get it let's do it
look to get candy on a two-day contract
and click clean up but there's going to
be uh google and
the likes of the big companies competing
so that should be a lot of fun
and more on the streaming side we have
arena kings
that is happening mondays and fridays
there's a 20 000
prize fund so that's something to keep
your eyes on your favorite streamers are
pretty much always playing in that
weekly
uh myself over the chess bras play at
cantee you've seen him do some
commentary i know you play when you can
uh james but fun a fun tournament you
know for for anybody to try to win it's
not like
the same players win every time the
lower rated guys can still get a win in
there
that is correct we're excited for rainy
kings you can play mondays and fridays
that's right and you know without
further ado there's lots of stuff
happening at chess.com so we want to
make sure to let you guys know about the
upcoming events but
the most important upcoming event right
now is the bullet portion
of this match james i mean one plus one
we've been speculating
you know who might be the favorite going
in but how do you feel just maybe about
the momentum of these players going into
this match momentum wise teddy
definitely has a huge momentum here uh
charissa yip is like i gotta win
i have to play i have to get in the zone
basically and sometimes you go into a
zone
where you just run off games no matter
who's in front of you so that's what
karissa yipp needs to go into that
moment
or spend some time in the hyperbolic
chamber right now and actually uh
do her thing and come out very strong so
let's see what happens here
one second increment they're using the
same openings too same stuff
bishop f5 a new move from teddy i think
you did queen b8 last time so
slightly different here and you know
we'll see what they have prepared but
that plus one
does change it you know a player who's
uh used to playing online
uh they play one minute with zero
seconds right
right so that one second it really does
throw off those bullet players who think
you know oh it's bullet i'll just clean
up in that section
um but that's not the case at all
exactly here and bullet of course is
that one second increment it's still
bullet chest
and when you get to five six seconds
that one second doesn't help as much as
you think it does
so here you want to be very smart with
the time here teddy is down 10 seconds
and then in bullet that's a lot of time
that lays down a lot of time being down
10 to 12 seconds
already here with white having pretty
easy position i would say
i see g4 g5 coming quickly getting the
king out of the way on b1
she's taking his extra pawn i'm liking
white's position already this is what
carissa needs
quickly easy positions to play which
gives you nice moves and nice play
so it's not too tactical where you have
to spend so much time with the accuracy
parts
yeah and and uh i'm wondering about
trading queens because i almost feel
like if you keep the queens on the board
that oh bishop b5 though that force is a
queen tree that's a strange i think
that's a strong movement whoa 93 that's
not a move get him off the
board oh my goodness teddy that's a bad
thing for him oh man teddy ain't ready
oh man teddy not ready he wasn't ready
for it
queen defense i think carissa is feeling
good
starting off this uh this board rook one
and yeah
she should clean up this game up 15
seconds plus 10
on the board right and he and a smart
advantage or a smart uh way to keep
playing for teddy is just keep the clock
running keep the clock running so you
have to play every game out
no resignations every game should be
played out to
its entirety until the clock runs out
and rookie seven is going to happen
takes and queen d6
yeah it's pretty easy yeah yeah this is
out here
this is out just making moves it's kind
of hurt like
when you know you're just getting
crushed and you're like well i just got
to keep moving because of the time
like i'm getting crushed right now but
i'm just going to keep playing here
that's always a tough situation when
you're getting destroyed and you're just
sitting there
and hoping it's over soon yep
that's all that's going on right now and
uh
teddy knows that he's mark look at him
sitting and stalling too
like he knows what he's doing right now
yeah it's very smart and then all you
just got to
keep it keep the clock running what a
smart man
teddy's over here getting crushed but
i'm just gonna take my time
i'm gonna take my absolute here my
absolute
he has a four game lead and he's
thinking match strategy
he's saying uh you know hmm i'm really
gonna have seven
and this is good stuff too like he's
trying this
no there's no still man in there that
was a nice check gg there
wow yeah and a big start for carissa yet
it's now eight and a half to five and a
half
only a three game lead uh for teddy
coleman here and
carissa is surging if we're talking
momentum i'm saying look
carissa has got to be absolutely
satisfied with what's happened in the
last couple games a big win at the end
of the three minute portion
and a fantastic start to the bullet
absolutely after that last win there it
was
awesome for her she's in the element
here this is a better king's indian it
looks like
for both of them actually i think they
played this pretty well
already this city seems pretty good
usually the knight this is a way to play
i do know king's indian theory here is
the knight over from d7 to b6 you also
have the knight eight seven ways where
you're going to break with f6
uh eventually here but this is more
attacking like i'll do like the 97 ip6
myself
here so let's see look what teddy did he
did knight h3 and brought the knight to
f2 thank goodness you know that knight
is not staying on h3 the whole game oh
man thanks teddy huge
oh my goodness it's game over oh she's
swinging hey hey
tapped him on the shoulder he turned
around and she hit him as hard as he
could
and he drops he's dropping
wow that's another one karissa yip is
turning up now
okay she came to play you know she came
to play you cannot count her out of this
one
absolutely no i think this is anybody's
match right now wow
20 minutes left and we're good we have a
crazy match unfolding right
check out the check out the bullet
ratings actually i just noticed that
teddy's not he doesn't be you know maybe
he doesn't play that much bullet but
he that's a difference that is the
difference and it's
slightly showing right now slightly
showing
what i remember is that teddy played
levy
and what was crazy was levy you know
levi's rating and boy
i mean so much higher than teddy's but
teddy held his own in the bullet portion
so again i don't think he's
i don't think he plays that much but you
just can see like
he's capable of just hanging with uh the
very best
so hanging with that bullet is uh scary
very scary
levy and bullet but uh here i mean dang
just like he's must be hanging out he's
not hanging with this one
no not this one he's just hanging with
this one guys
oh man yeah this is uh this is amazing
amazing
she has to keep it up if you have four
there's 20 minutes left with only
two if she she finishes off it will be
only
two points yeah will she come back
so the important thing for me right here
is she needs to just move that bishop
on a g7 if you don't use that piece you
don't really feel your advantage and
finally there she goes
it doesn't matter about the pawn it's
more you just need to get that bishop
into the game
absolutely great great point you just
have to get the bishop into the game
because
like it's queen tonight versus queen and
light square bishop
because the dark square bishop's just
chilling over there and also f6 should
should be played it should have been
played already but f6 is fine
now 58 now bishop
that's beautiful queen b6
he's trying to keep up the time though
the very smart play from um
from teddy here as the clock runs out he
will be the victor here if it ends
right now so he needs to to keep the
clock running
yeah just bishop b3 or bishop d3 here
there's
lots of mates on the board nicely done
nicely
another win yes he's swinging chris
fighting back fighting back just like
that and here's e4
e5 okay and we got a vienna she's gonna
hit him with that gambit
she loves that stuff oh she
didn't this time is it f4 now oh she
didn't do it at all
really that's interesting i remember her
playing a lot of early f4s
this one's very early though this one's
yeah this one's too early but she takes
that f4 i like this vienna she plays
yep solid solid opening
wow
okay a3 a6 knight f3
knight in many cases knight g4 is knight
g5 so bishop g4 was played
i haven't played this in a while yeah 92
i used to play
vienna a little bit yeah
so that so basically bishop takes um two
bishops for white now
queen h4 the idea for teddy and that
means you can't really hang on to that
bishop you can't go like bishop d2
because queen h4 comes in quick as a
flash so um
bishop pair is not in carissa's hands
anymore but
i mean he can't really hate on the
position board position
i like knight f4 here well actually
knight d4 but that knight is really
strong on f4
uh oh she had an xc3 for knight d5 same
intention
but i had two choices even h5 or d5s in
some cases
so that was the the intention there g3
is very weak yikes
very very annoying move queen g5 i mean
e3's an idea
knight d4 i don't know um i'm definitely
liking blacks to counter play here
black's definitely all in the position
here i can't castle my dark squares
aren't mine hang on oh that's the rap
yeah that's a wrap snap snap have a good
day
that's over yeah this is not how you
play the queen g2
queen g2 and then knight takes f3 king
d1 and they have good
that's what check flex real hard oh but
you remember knight
f3 there's there's 95 and rook f1 this
could be a blunder
yeah you actually right i forgot about
rook f1 hitting f7
and knight d5 you're actually right bro
oh 95 is good oh takes takes am i
getting the same
wow good play here good play good play
for both sides i think black's gonna end
up just a little bit ahead but
um carissa can't have done any better
yikes he getting both the pawns
over there can you just wait oh h6 yeah
that works same thing
the same idea i'll get tonight when i
want to yep
get tonight when i want bishop d5 uh
rook b8
probably just get out of the pan but
that's that's very passive rick f8 i
like it
i mean but not really good game so far
by both players there's tactics
all over the place but uh it's actually
wound up that the pawns are even
surprisingly if teddy loses this is
three games in a row do you notice that
come on
that's three that's three in a row from
carissa if he loses this game and he's a
favorite to lose it we say it because
he's down on time
now this is a time scramble but he got
less time
yeah bishop to g4 very nice maybe bishop
f5 clamping down
four seconds left for teddy here he has
to move faster he's just losing
he's just growing yeah she's gonna take
this one i believe she's gonna as long
as she doesn't blunder away her life
he takes c4 he's good i think white
spawns move faster than black spawns
here c5 d5
oh yeah those center pawns you're
correct c5
oh you want to advance the dark squares
right oh king e5
right uh wow here it was made oh my
goodness e5 this is d6 mate
or bishop uh c3 yikes
king d3 uh did we just no i don't take
that don't take that
okay this should be i think this should
be winning for black but
she had to play a4 a3 there's a big
chance there
oh snap nope she's good bishop b6 that
was cheering
six was needed yeah should be six
well not bishop e7
yeah that was that even think about the
other move
is this winning is this gg oh this is
definitely winning
oh my goodness game over because the
bishop is gonna go to b6 queen check
queen check with check what check
clean what are you doing queen oh my
goodness
what is this yes still winning
okay king b7 and push the pawn up yeah
oh my goodness and i move the bishop out
of there and
teddy is gonna win this game wow and he
needed to breathe you see him breathing
oh man i was getting killed out there
coach
hey stop me out coach sub me please sub
me
man it was like oh man
oh man that was tough she was playing so
good
yeah well and this is something i'm
honestly surprised that she doesn't have
internalized but
when you have opposite bishops if you
have the light squirt bishop and your
opponent has a dark square bishop when
you have pass funds you advance them on
the opposite color of your bishop and
that is just
that's just the rule so when she played
d5 the the black
uh king and bishop went in on the
blockade and it was over for the rap
yeah but anyways we're on to the next
game and that's how quick bullet moves
uh carissa already to me this opening is
working well against teddy's uh
weirdness eddie center yeah i'm liking
it right i'm liking it
as well and bishop c4 yeah great move
here i mean
pressure on the file or the diagonal so
we argue yeah castle is correct we are
giving
up e3 oh that's kind of weird by the way
yeah yikes yeah this isn't good no more
it's not looking too good no more not at
all
the rookie 8 is nice though because you
hit the knight and the bishop behind it
is being hit
everything is hanging almost basically
yeah there's so many so takes takes and
then bishop f5 and we live okay knight
around
and oh i'm second nah never mind queen
takes e3 check
i was gonna sack on f5 oh you might have
to though
maybe yes so this is this means the f7
pawn is hanging but knight a5
looks strong is bishop seven the move
yes it is he found it
dang good stuff teddy takes takes g4
that's what it is
man boy tactics man yeah i hope you did
your puzzle rush today in the chat i
hope you did you puzzle rush
so that's exactly what this is but a lot
of bullet is
puzzle rush when you get these kind of
positions take on f7 if queen takes we
traded queens play g4
right so a5 is hanging rick f8 is a move
so
what about knight c f8 looks great yeah
cafe oh but it's a lot of stuff hanging
yeah so many things are hanging here a
lot of stuff hanging
g4 oh right and you see him like
can i just play g4 that's exactly what
he said can i just play g4
bro he just did it and he plays it there
it is g4
okay but you know 16 seconds that king
wide open
this is anyone's game in my opinion uh
yes anyone's game absolutely anyone's
game
absolutely even though i'm getting this
what
wow does that work that does work
rick takes c7 i mean what are we
thinking about and then so if that
knight gets attacked
like bring the rook back from d5 right
oh
nice we're taking and those bishops can
still be dangerous here
i gotta get rid of one of them now oh
yeah king f2 i was gonna play knight f6
but that hangs a pawn
i was trying to get rid of one of those
knights
oh my god bishop d4 bishop d4
oh you missed it yeah you're right
though bishop d4 was nasty that was hard
not that it's hard to see but man that
was a sequence right there this is rick
b2
rick b2 yeah what do you do rick c1 okay
he's going to take the file
rook c3 probably try to get out of this
pin with king e1
or king d1 better move getting closer
take take
carissa is everything that gets this way
too i gotta yeah she's doing everything
three to four seconds here on the clock
yo oh my goodness three to four seconds
bishop b4 maybe she's gonna go the
king's too close now dang yeah
check no mating sequences that was not
that good i don't think she should have
no mating sequences here come the pawns
but i'm not sure if it's in time
it's just a it's just a straight race
here look at the time for teddy you move
with 0.2 seconds
oh my gosh echoing the clock flex your
heart move the knight out of the way
okay try to oh she just forgot oh my god
it's over no
no so right now
i'm looking at the overall match clock
and i'm saying
look if you're carissa it's now you win
every single game and that's the only
avenue to victory you
have to win every single game you have
to win every single game
you have to so nerve-racking those time
scrambles when it's like zero point and
you're like oh my god just make a move
just put something on the board
yikes that rook check oh man it was so
hard
this is the hardest part right here this
is always the hardest part of the match
is the bullet portion
yeah yikes so i i do not think it's over
yet i think there is maybe
just enough time uh for for four
victories yeah
she's gonna have to basically yeah but
the thing is she's gotta get three
victories and then even if the last game
starts
with one second on the game clock it
still counts it still counts
yeah you're right yes so there is enough
time guys there really is
but carissa has simply got to win this
game and there's no way around it
there's no way around it correct
knight takes h4 wow we already have
something new here
not familiar with this one yeah taking
pawns i'm a pawn grabber as well yeah i
was going to say
f5 what okay
uh that's dynamic like who would you
like i'm not actually sure who would i
want in this position yet
i'm not so i'm look if you need to win a
game
i like the fact that it's in balance
it's messy who cares if you're carissa
you're happy to get this
right that's correct that's like castle
hitting e4
long castle yeah yeah i'm getting out
the way have a nice day castle
queen side other side of civilization
put the rooks on g1 whoa
that's a little scary you could always
take that anyway like the bishop was ben
i don't think that was necessary right
now yeah you have to get the king out of
the center
castle queen side and then you f3 was
actually even a better move
bishop takes e4 i would never play that
teddy what are you doing
he he's saying that to himself too what
am i doing i'm not myself right now
that's exactly right takes h5 takes h5
yep
and carissa is just trying to throw
every pawn off the starting square
doesn't care look at that e5
just sacrificing i mean look at this
kind of chest today bishop c5 and we
live it looks like we're crushing but
it's not it's running yeah it's crazy
but that king is running
that's crazy sometimes chess is a
miraculous game bishop b6 is a real
threat broke a6 oh
should be six anyway and then he
plays king ca so we're good to go
great movie teddy so maybe yeah queen b6
queen b6 and just probably castle
queenside
it's you have done this too much your
king has been sitting here it's way too
long
yeah yeah i think that's fair rick takes
a two king b-1
king b-1 yeah king b-1 get out of the
way and then we're going to team a4
though
queen a4 is tricky oh that's mate huh
bishop a3 then
needed and play big move and then c5
queen c5 after uh rook takes a3
fantastic find that should be it and she
needs that there it is
there it is hitting him in his lip
wow hitting him back swinging back just
like that look at her work
she's doing some work here guys let her
work now
of course teddy is very smart with the
clock here he needs to keep working the
clock
he needs to keep working the clock here
because carissa is on fire
she's she's definitely catching some
heat here and she's ready
but the time you want hanging it's not
her friend
yeah he wants hanging queen to be three
that's a win on time that's huge
he could have prolonged that game for a
long time a long time
yeah wow
it's a three-game match good job carissa
three-game match she keeping it very
close here
six remember it's just two wins just
just need two wins
then you start that third game and
there's at least a chance
yeah you're so right yeah two wins from
her
she needs to give everything she's got
here everything she's got
it has to be this opening has been
working online yeah this has been
working
yeah big fan of this opening
something like takes and i mean it's
knight takes e5 it means bishop b5 of c6
i
don't think this is really that
dangerous yeah at all
actually castles i mean kind of an even
game white has an isolated pawn in the
center
i mean it's easy plans when you have the
isolated pawn strategically you have a
plan already put the knight on d5
trade pieces and put the heavy zone into
the files that's it
uh so you don't even think about this
i'm starting to wonder
why didn't carissa play this uh the
whole game
the whole match sorry yeah right the
whole match yeah it's a great setup and
it's worth
every single time that's right that's
right this could be a whole different
game here
a whole different match a whole
different match there we are just put
the rooks on the file with a smile
rookie a rook d8
and just kind of chill and you know
improve the position slowly
yeah that's it this is strategically one
but you it's
you know also could be drawn as well but
many times
one thing i think the bigger issue is
that if this is winning for carissa
it's not gonna be winning for a while
you know like
it's going to be a it's going to be a
grind so i think she's playing well but
teddy is saying look
i need to run this clock down there's
five under five minutes left
if i get a grindy game where i might be
a little bit worse but hey
um you know it's milk the clock
milk the clock yeah milk the clock here
queen to c4
and yeah i think b6 might have been a
mistake there because the c6 is weak now
so and that's the pressure is now gone
and yeah we're doing good as y here uh
teddy's doing so great
look how quick she's playing though to
her credit uh whether
she's playing the best moves or not look
at the time he's down to 14 seconds this
is exactly what she needs to do she
needs to play as
fast as humanly possible that's right as
fast as humanly
she's playing really fast too like 37
she's been up a lot of time here i mean
she's definitely showing some strength
here and bullet
definitely showing some straight than
bullet like wow i mean great performance
here
um regardless even after the slips we've
had and the issues today
she has uh made it pretty a pretty close
match still
mm-hmm knight to c3 coming
and rookie one rookie one night one yeah
that is the nastier movie oh you see
that
won nicely three minutes he chopped out
beautiful or she was like nah i'm not
standing there bro
i'm not about to stay in there okay
knight d2
you know she's not taking the draw i
mean even when she was losing him
all right i mean come on d5c
man rookie i can just take that can't i
it's so close to me
i probably don't want to take it but
just capture it like why not whatever
take take
but look at the time running down it's
three minutes 30 seconds and after this
game
it's looking like it's only one more
that's tough right there
and she still hasn't won this game yet
that's that's still in the
it doesn't look like she is going to win
this one either day based off of uh play
now rookie two was a shot
or uh it was checked so we couldn't do
that
it doesn't look like either side's gonna
win this so i mean of course
yeah this bullet we don't know yeah we
don't know what's about to happen right
now
but it looks like black is doing fine
but white's doing okay too
check knight before knight c6 take on a7
yeah and now now rookie two there we go
black's doing well yeah
knight takes and just clean up on the
the bishop beats the knight here
defending pawns this is good stuff for
carissa
oh take those pawns
she's playing very well uh she's just
basically uh
turning it on at the wrong moment you
know just a little bit earlier was
needed
that's it i mean yeah teddy can yeah
it's two minutes left
man that's like one she's got this win
she's got this win that's like one game
she's like one game off
yep one game off rook g6 had pushed the
pawns
he's gonna hide yeah
it's almost a minute now yeah she's
milking the clock here
great milking of the clock here no
resigns
yep and and you know you wonder you know
do those 30 seconds that he spent
earlier in the match
during the clock does that matter well
yeah it looks down to it now it comes
quite valuable yeah it's quite valuable
yeah that's a great match strategy for
even
you know going forward for people
playing in these events just
how to milk the clock and use the time
to your advantage maybe using all of
your time even in positions where you're
up maybe if you've got a two game lead
wait a while before you make the mate
you know stuff like that so
this is this is a situation where
carissa
nearly needs to pre-move the entire
match yeah there's a minute and a half
left
and he's got a minute on his clock with
plus one second i think the match is
over
especially with a guy like teddy who's
so conscious of that clock situation
um i think that that he is minimum going
to win this match by by a point here
yeah he's uh yeah minimum by a point yes
to too gay i mean she made a comeback
for real
if there was more time she the momentum
how was swinging
she would have caught up i think she
would have caught up here
the way to see
two moves yeah 56 under a minute guys
under a minute it's does not yeah this
this game is way too far away
because i mean there's like 40 seconds
on teddy's clock and there's nearly 40
seconds on the match clock so
at some point he can literally just wind
it down um
plus he doesn't even have a bad position
like you know we're not even talking
about that
yeah here you can honestly just chill
and do whatever here i remember in the
last bullet game with levy he promoted
to an
under promotion to a knight it was
actually pretty funny it was like oh
night it was like great it was a great
moment so
here understanding a great match
strategy here from teddy
as he's going to walk away today's
winner
yeah absolutely as we see that match
clock slowly dying on the hopes of
carissa yip as she made an incredible
comeback and pretty much did exactly
what she needed to do
in the bullet but uh maybe just dropped
too many games early on to the you know
the
the queens that were hanging and the
clock situation
and the disconnects a few things didn't
go her way because the bullet
is i mean we've just seen a whole
different character man this is not the
same carissa that came in today
when this bullet she just came and
showed every bit of the 2457 rating
right now
which is uh man she's a force to be
reckoned with
and that is officially we just announce
it for everybody that that is officially
the
last match uh sorry the last game of the
match of the one minute portion and of
the entire match
so um it is going to be uh
it is going to be over ggs
ggs
carissa of course they're going to
finish this game i mean carissa can
bring this back to a very respectable
one
you know one game difference with a win
here
one game difference i mean extremely
close match here
one game difference here it all came
down to the bullet section luckily
if it wasn't for teddy being up four
games i mean this could be
the other way this could have went the
other way it was even for a while
then he got up to four games and but if
it was even going into the bullet
right now she would be up she would be
up right now
winning the match full credit to teddy i
mean
uh and that is gonna be a win by timeout
i
don't think teddy he's gonna be too
upset when he realizes or
probably already knows the match is
officially over uh he has one so it's
ten and a half to 90 and a half and as i
as i said she's going to bring the match
back to within one game
james and i mean now that we're at the
end of it all that the heart rate is
starting to settle down
any final thoughts before we get into
the interviews oh man i think it was a
great match i think uh
the blitz portion there was of course
mistakes as all chess has there was
mistakes teddy was just proving
better in the blitz he was just playing
better and making the better moves and
blitz and
of course uh in the bullet carissa yipp
definitely turned it on
she turned it on but i think it was a
little bit too late at that point
yeah and that's that's a pretty good
summary honestly um we are going to see
if we can get the players
uh around for a post-match interview
which is staple at the end of these
i am not a gm events um so congrats to
teddy coleman he comes with the victory
today but myself james
i will be joined by the players
hopefully right after this so stick
around
and welcome back myself and mr canty
here are joined by the players we have
teddy coleman and carissa yep uh here
for the post-match interview
teddy a wild match you know it actually
came down to 10 and a half to nine and a
half
you looked like in that final portion
that you were maybe checking the game
clock was that something you were very
conscious of as carissa was mounting a
comeback
yeah no absolutely i was checking it
from time to time because um
i remember my match against danny last
year i went into the bullet
up four games also and he forced an
armageddon so i was like oh my god
especially after i lost the first two
games i was like oh my god please don't
happen again
and so you know obviously carissa just
played so much better than i did in the
bullet so i was
i was lucky to survive that one
yeah i mean the the match clock is part
of it as well and
and carissa i i do not take pleasure in
reminding you about these things but
there are a lot of games that you
probably wish you had back there were
some queen hangs
there was like some missing taking back
a queen and then
also the disconnect i mean you played so
well in the bullet do you think back on
some of those games as
maybe where you could have had the
chance to win this match
i mean yeah i ended up being really
close and
like right now i'm just thinking only
didn't play like rick f3 and actually
took back the queen
because i was getting like super
stressed and i thought he was gonna play
like
rookie one or something he missed i had
rick f went after it and then he took
the queen but my mouse was already like
on the rook
and i was trying to take the queen back
that's what it meant and that didn't
happen
so yeah yeah no that's exactly what i
was saying at the time but man yeah
yeah i think that also happened to me in
the game when
uh i think i had like rook rook
checkmate but instead like
i because i didn't think you were gonna
allow it so i had my rook like hovering
over the
the pond to take it and then you queened
and i took it anyway and i was like oh
my gosh
oh yeah
yeah and teddy you're ever the animated
player so
it's in moments like that that we can
all visually see exactly what's going on
like you're hovering rook a2 you
actually take rook a1 the evaluation bar
goes from made in one back to
0.00 and i mean was it was this a
crazy match for you in terms of the
emotional side of things
yeah no i definitely am a very emotional
player
and something that robert house likes to
make fun of me a lot for um
and yeah i think it just totally shows
and i think chris on the other hand just
kind of sits there cool as a cucumber so
i probably could take a few pointers
from you on that
solo facade i mean trembling
shaking on the inside you know
james and i couldn't tell i can say that
yeah we couldn't tell what worked well
for you karissa in the bullet portion
you were going crazy actually
we felt that you were just we saw
another carissa in the bullet here
what worked well for you in the bullet
i mean i guess like well i feel like
first of all teddy
is a lot better at blitz than bullet
and um i guess at that point i was just
trying to like
make moves as quickly as possible like
sometimes when i overthink things
the move i end up playing is just not as
good
so yeah i feel like i do better in
bullet than blitz usually
excellent that's a fair assessment
there's actually one uh of your openings
that i wanted to ask you because based
on the games
that i saw i don't think teddy was
handling your
g6 bishop g7 e6 knight e7 set up very
well and i was thinking like man what if
carissa played this the whole match
um did you did you feel like that
because the openings you were getting
looked tremendous especially in the
bullet section
um yeah i mean i'm pretty comfortable in
the king's indian and like this g6 e6
thing is a
thing that my friend taught me shout out
to craig hilby
yeah i usually like it's not very sound
so i tried to
play it in like bullet time controls i'm
pretty sure teddy would have found a
better way to handle it if i played it
more in the glitch
right yeah i don't know i
honestly was not super prepared for it
and you
yeah i honestly felt like in general
when i had the white pieces
you were just completely out playing me
like almost every single king's indian
ended up being bad for me you know i
tried to play some of these lines where
i just played like hey you know d4
knight f3 bishop
g5 or bishop f4 and those weren't going
well so
yeah i don't know i think i got a lot to
think about after this one
one of the yeah that's a good point
that's what prep looks like you're gonna
have to come into the next match
thinking about these things that
that uh maybe chris has uncovered in
this match one of the things that i
noticed about karissa
and so much credit to her for this is
that never give up style
is like when there's a draw on the board
carissa
it's not even registering to her that
it's there she's always thinking about a
way to play on
and sometimes she would lose a game from
that but there were a lot of examples
where she won a game at the critical
moment i mean teddy
what do you think about that style of
you know you almost expect
her to play on in every position yeah i
mean
look i think in the whatever 20 games i
think we only had one draw
which is crazy um
and you know i i mean coming into this
match i was honestly
also just pretty nervous because someone
like carissa is already
like incredibly talented and only
getting better every day
and um you know yeah i think she had
great you know just great fighting
spirit and every game was a slugfest and
yeah definitely you know like we talked
about earlier i was definitely feeling
the heat and feeling the stress in it
okay i was i was really stressed too
we can do definitely not
uh james and i were we were thoroughly
entertained um
i mean looking forward in the uh in the
bracket
teddy i mean you've you've come away
with the win today you're playing
against uh lars oscar houg in the next
uh match as per the bracket i mean um
not something you've given any thought
to yet i'm sure taking it one match at a
time but
um any plans for going into the next
round in terms of
what you might do differently yeah um
you know i think last year when i played
this um
you know i lost pretty badly to elena
she crushed me and so seeing lars
um i think he won like six or seven in a
row in the bullet against delena
um i know i probably need to just
practice a ton of bullet otherwise i
think i'm in
big big big trouble yeah gotcha
gotcha well that was a an exciting match
to be sure it ended up being just a
single game so
um i i felt that that was an incredibly
close match and just
a little bit extra time in the bullet
and who knows carissa gets another game
and
that dreaded armageddon that uh that you
were scared of teddy might have happened
but
uh big congrats uh teddy for your match
victory today
carissa we're sorry it didn't go your
way you know the disconnection as well
um nothing seemed to be going your way
this match but uh we were thoroughly
entertained and i think i speak for
the chat james and myself that your
style of chess
is like super entertaining very
aggressive style tactical
we just had a a lot of fun commentating
this match today
thanks guys we really appreciate it
thanks good luck teddy
thanks thanks guys and
that is uh it's going to conclude
today's match james we have the bracket
on the screen there as players uh
moving on to the next round you can see
they've advanced uh teddy is one of
those players and
we've already talked about some of the
other first round matchups james and you
were hinting at some of them that caught
your eye
actually absolutely well of course now
i'm definitely interested in that teddy
coleman lars oscar match of course
because he's what he said teddy's
correct like he has to
improve his bullet here as lars is i
think he's 2 700 in both
at least i think yeah blitz and bullets
so he's uh
super super strong so teddy has a lot of
uh a lot up for um for grabs for him but
eric rosen cigar i'm not really familiar
with uh cigar yet but eric rosen of
course we know is super strong here
and gostia and tanya that's going to be
a nice matchup there i don't know who's
a favorite there
yeah no so those are the upcoming
matches i'm not a gm continues of course
we also have arena kings
i want to make sure you guys are uh
keeping track of everything chess.com is
hosting here there's so many things
upcoming
so we have lots more of these commentary
uh commentary i am not a gm but twenty
thousand dollar prize find arena kings
you know the top streamers that you all
know about hikaru we've seen uh
we've seen you know the the likes of
levy and just all those big streamers
you guys like to follow
you know chess brawls get in there from
time to time candy himself
so prize is up for steak uh up up
for grabs rather and it's just a really
fun tournament to play and watch no
matter what your rating is so mondays
and fridays tune in
to arena kings and what about pogchamps
three
james that that i mean we just got so
many things to remind people of
presented by grip6 the the players that
are competing
in pogchamps i mean you might recognize
some of them from the streaming world
but the most interesting thing is
bringing in the people from outside we
have code miko
the tuber we also have people from so
many different disciplines like daniel
negrano
over playing poker and coming in playing
some chess we also have rayne wilson
uh ludwig logic you mentioned the the
decorated rapper that he is
just so many exciting people um of all
sorts of backgrounds competing in this
uh james absolutely and mr beast too of
course a youtube
monster just uh blowing up everything in
youtube right now having him is just uh
it's awesome guys and this is only just
the beginning
yeah absolutely and one of the uh more
interesting and unique events on the
calendar is actually the feed eight
online
corporate uh championship so this is
happening uh
february 19th 21st um
take note of that but that's going to be
pretty exciting and you mentioned to me
james that you know even the powerhouse
of google has has signed up there so
we're just waiting to see the full list
of companies that are going to
participate
but that should be kind of a unique
event where you get to see
uh you know which company has the best
chess players on offer
that's gonna be fun to watch actually
i'm gonna check that coverage too i'm
watching paul
champs i'm watching arena kings i'm
playing like we're doing everything guys
and you want to get involved too
chat this is was just for you yeah and
i mean just just mark your calendars
because you don't want to miss any of
these things
there's so many things going on that
chess.com is hosting and it's going to
be live commentary as always
um you know it doesn't matter what the
team is chess.com has always got the the
best of the best whatever duo there's
gonna be
um hopefully you and myself get to work
uh together again in the near future
james because it was a uh
it was a pleasure today that was a
really fun match tons of tactics i had a
great time
it was great man i had a great time too
great time with the chat great chess
it's just
all great right here at chess.com man
come on
what are you talking about you know it's
great i love it and we're going to keep
the action going because i think we're
going to be sending the raid off to anna
chess
anna rudolph and i think she's doing a
lesson a coaching session with michelle
carr who's just
on that pog champs three uh introductory
list of participants they're doing a
coaching session
in preparation for pogchamps three so
that's where the raid is going
congrats to teddy coleman james any last
words for the people out there
do you puzzle rush guys do you puzzle us
every single day go on chess.com
learn puzzle rush and have a nice day
there you go take care guys and thanks
for watching
you